in Sydney Prescott's room next to her
desk there's a poster for swamp ofilia
an album by the Indigo Girls a filk rock
band from the 1980s as you can see on
this poster the band is a two-piece the
latest single from that album at the
time that scream came out was also
called The Power of Two this is symbolic
because of the twist in Scream the fact
that there are two killers the power of
two is the reason that they were able to
trick police and clear Billy's name as a
Suspect with this in mind we can go back
and find many more clues about scream's
Double Trouble antagonist to learn the
connection between stocker's room and
the video rental store stick around to
the end of this video
[Music]
everybody knows that scream is a satire
a horror movie that makes a commentary
about horror movies but I think a lot of
people Overlook what a satire actually
is so let's take it back to the basic
definition satire is the use of humor
irony exaggeration or ridicule to expose
and criticize something by that
definition satire has always been around
long before scream and long before
movies even the slasher genre had
already come out with films like student
bodies or Evil Dead 2 so let's just drop
the charade that scream is some kind of
first ofit kind movie but one of the
things that makes scream loved by many
is its ability to Satur without turning
to Comedy which led to it being a
legitimate force in the genre that it
was aiming to expose in fact scream was
so successful and so many tried to
imitate it that it's acute
self-awareness became the norm for a
while audiences had seen this happen in
television a few years earlier with the
Simpsons the family sitcom which
attacked the positive family values of
other sitcoms in the air of the time wow
it must be expensive to produce all
these cartoons well we cut corn is
sometimes to save money our animators
will reuse the same backgrounds over and
over and over again as a result
everybody wanted to make a show with
that cuttingedge social commentary like
The Simpsons but the Simpsons was a
comedy a comedy that made fun of the TV
families of the80s then surpassed them
and became the TV family of the90s
scream was able to follow this blueprint
but for horror movies you can make the
argument that scream is funny but it's a
different kind of funny it's pretty
clear that the intention is not to have
you as they put it in the 9s RL but that
isn't to say that screenwriter Kevin
William Williamson and director Wes
Craven don't understand the formula of
setup and punchline they actually
transform that concept and use it for
some scares in the movie instead of
laughs for example there are a number of
scenes that end with a big push into to
a spot in the background where ghost
face can be seen lurking we see this
outside of Sid's house and at the
grocery store so we start to associate
that particular camera movement with the
appearance of our antagonist when Tatum
is getting beers from the garage we see
the camera brush past her and focus on
the door frend it starts to elevate our
heart rates but then nothing happens
that's such a clever way to build
suspense then we see the door close but
it's just the cat so we're no longer on
edge making it all the more effective
when Ghost Face does appear in front of
the closed door there are other
techniques like this used to throw off
the audience and of course some clever
Easter eggs from West Craven so let's
get into the things you
miss even the title scream feels like
it's poking fun at some of the so simple
it could be about anything titles of
Alfred Hitchcock's horror movies like
blackmail murder sabotage rope and of
course psycho the beginning of scream
pulls out a trick that was used in
psycho psycho came out in 1960 and its
biggest star was its female lead Janet
Lee who played Mary and crane she is
prominently featured on the poster so
audiences were totally shocked when they
killed her off very early on in the
movie scream's biggest star is Drew
Barrymore who is similarly the face of
the marketing campaign so many people
were shocked to see her brutally
disemboweled in the opening scene
there's kind of a lineage that exists
connecting the most prominent slasher
movie of each generation when I covered
Halloween here on things you missed I
spent a lot of time talking about how it
was inspired by psycho now the torch is
being passed down yet again to scream we
can see this in the name Lumis psycho
had Samuel Lumis Halloween had Dr Sam
Lumis and scream had Billy Lumis who
after revealing he's one of the killers
drops a quote from
psycho we all go a little mad sometimes
Billy is also most likely the one on the
phone at the beginning who asked Casey
to guess his favorite horror movie
nightmare Elm Street I like that movie
it was scary well well the first one was
but the rest sucked I was about to get
up here and say that this was a joke by
director Wes Craven who also directed
the first Nightmare on Elm Street but
not the five sequels that would follow
but apparently that was in the script
before it was ever decided that Craven
would be the director I kind of wanted
to take that out you know I did not
write that line that answers my other
question about that line Wes returned to
the franchise to direct West Craven's
New Nightmare in case you didn't know
who the director of West Craven's New
Nightmare was it was Wes Craven which
was the most recent Freddy Krueger movie
at the time that scream was made it just
seems strange that he would diss himself
like that apparently the line later on
where Tatum mixes him up with Halloween
director John Carpenter duck other said
you're starting to sound like some West
Carpenter flick or something was also in
the script before Craven's involvement
but it kind of works better now seeing
how Scream uses Halloween as a template
for the horror movie tropes that it
[Music]
sazesh face looking around for her my
question is why doesn't he just try
calling the phone again and going
towards the sound of the ringtone it
seems logical that she would keep the
phone on her to try to get help so she
might have forgotten to silence it after
Ghostface catches up with her there are
a couple of Easter eggs that play out on
the Becker's side
[Music]
long as I mentioned Halloween is the
main template that scream uses for its
satire it's the movie that Casey's
planning to watch in the opening and
it's the movie that crushes Stu's head
in the finale there's another Halloween
connection after Casey manages to get
outside and see her parents going back
into the house despite the title of this
movie she is unable to find her scream
and get her parents
attention in Halloween 2 we see the same
phenomenon take place as Lorie stroe
tries to yell for help outside of the
haddenfield
hospital then there's yet another
Halloween reference just moments later
get in the car drive down to the
Mackenzie call the police when Lori and
the kids are targeted by Michael she
gives them a similar order I want you go
down the street to the MacKenzie's house
I want you to tell them to call the
police I'm sure there will be a lot of
people that already know about that
Easter egg and honestly quite a few of
the eggs in this movie are pretty common
knowledge because of the nature of
scream I mean it's basically a movie
that's loaded with references and nods
so it's going to attract people who
already know about that stuff on things
you missed I try to stick to things that
you might have missed that's why it's
called that if you didn't know however
if I leave the ones out that everybody
knows then there's going to be people in
the comments just complaining that I
missed stuff so let's just go through
the one that I think are more obvious
real quick and get them out of the way
Billy climbs through Sydney's window and
startles her just like Glenn did to
Nancy in a Nightmare on Elm Street
Sheriff Burke is played by the actor who
plays the police officer in Nightmare on
Elm Street Tatum's number 10 crop top is
very similar to a shirt worn by Glenn in
a Nightmare on Elm Street principal hry
has the following conversation with the
janitor damn little what you call
me huh not your friend that's director
West Craven choing as Fred which is
short for Freddy because he's dressed up
like Freddy Krueger from A Nightmare on
Elm Streets Fred
when ghost face pins down Sydney he
his head at just like Michael
Myers and the movie makes a point to
show that scene during Stu's party
Sydney refers to the town of Woodsboro
under curfew as the town that dreaded
Sundown and Randy who yells at the TV to
warn Jam Lee Curtis about the threat
behind her also has a threat behind him
Jamie look behind you look behind you
the actor that plays Randy is named
Jamie and he's being watched in a
similar manner by Kenny the news camera
guy and speaking of people named Jamie
Sydney at one point escapes from the
attic onto the roof like Jamie from
Halloween for I think those are all the
more well-known Easter eggs so let's get
into the fun stuff the less obvious ones
when Billy sneaks in his Sid's room he
tells her he was watching The Exorcist
on TV with all the good parts cut out
and it makes him think of their
relationship from this point they
continue to reference back to this idea
that their relationship is like a movie
after Sid's close call with Ghost Face a
reporter asks her so how does it feel to
be almost brutally butchered leave alone
people want to know they have a right to
know and this is a CIO by Linda Blair
she played Regan in The Exorcist 23
years ago if you're listening closely
during the Sydney and Billy scene you
you'll notice that there's a song
playing in the background it's an
acoustic cover of Don't Fear the Reaper
by Blue Oyster Cult a song that I like
but I'm starting to get a little tired
of hearing in movies and TV but I'll
save that ranch for a future video
because here there might be a good
reason for it it's the same song that
Lorie stro and Annie bracket listen to
in the car in Halloween and as I've said
many times already Halloween is the
template that scream builds off of there
could also be a second meaning here the
ghost face costume is essentially a
depiction of a grim reaper the name of
the costume itself in universe is Father
death the next day the school is buzzing
with rumor and news crews trying to
capitalize on the story we first see one
of our main characters Gail Weathers in
the background of an establishing shot
even though we don't end up going
towards her here the neon green outfit
in a sea of dull wardrobe colors draws
the eye and lets us know that she's
important it's like in a video game
where it'll only let you target
characters that you can actually talk to
that's good film making it's also kind
of a preview of how the movie ends but
Gail has a bloody lip and a red dress
during school that day each student is
called into the office for interrogation
there's a chart on the wall that details
which teachers are in which classrooms
each period most of the teachers names
are crew reference Easter eggs almost
all of these people refer to people in
the art Department who would have been
responsible for putting these
decorations on set they include
Carpenter Art Williams local lead person
Kenny montante additional set decorator
Deborah eard lead man Richard Lambert
set dresser Josh Elliot art Department
coordinator Charlene bar art director
David Luben driver Ben Davis and set
decorator Michelle pulik probably a very
unfortunate name to have grown up with
we actually see Michelle and put her
name into the movie a couple of times in
the hallway there's a poster advertising
Michelle pic for president a deliberate
missp sping of her name in the bathroom
there's some graffiti that says Michelle
plus Bob forever using the same
unconventional spelling as the set
decorator because of her situation with
her mom being killed a year prior the
media attention is very familiar for S
you know the police and reporters and
everything it's like deja vu all over
again that's a redundant statement that
would be like saying I went on a side
tangent or if I commented on scream's
acute self-awareness one of the things
that scream does to try to stay
interesting is play with our
expectations pay attention to the music
sting that happens when Sydney opens the
closet door
[Music]
using typical horror movie Logic the
audience can expect that this means a
scare is about to happen it's the
perfect setup for the classic
refrigerator door scare but when she
closes it nobody is there this also
establishes the idea that the closet
should be empty making it even better
when Ghost Face busts out of it 5
minutes later with the murders and all
it's like right out of a horror movie or
something we see more of that after
mentioned self-awareness as Sydney mocks
horror movies saying that they're the
same some stupid killer stalking some
big breasted girl who can't act who's
always running up the stairs when she
should be going out the front door it's
insulting only for her to do just that
when she can't figure out how to unlock
the front door I always love this next
part she calls the police on her PC
connects to someone seconds later and
the cops are at the door in 46 seconds
take notes uberit so Sydney is already
saved by the time Tatum shows up in her
red VW Beetle I don't know if this is
100% an intentional reference but since
it's scream I'll just assume that it is
this is the car that Jack Torrance
drives in the novel version of the sh CH
it appears in Stanley Kubrick's film
adaptation as well is the car that's
been crushed by an overturned truck
Kubrick's way of saying screw you King
I'm not going to follow the book of
course there is a more obvious Stephen
King reference later on corn syrup same
stuff they use for pigs blood and carry
Tatum also goes with to the police
station where they get some info from
Sydney her brother dwey tries to get her
to respect him while he's in uniform in
front of his Superior officer he's my
Superior janitor is your Superior which
is true on the film set since Wes Craven
the director plays the janitor
technically he's David Arquette's boss
Billy's name is cleared when Stu calls
Sydney again using the Ghostface voice
while Billy is still in custody Sheriff
Burke is no L I don't even know if he's
on the same level as Randy to be honest
he's got killer printed all over his for
which is exactly where Sydney shoots him
at the end of the movie Randy is
portrayed as the biggest horror buff in
the story he works at the video store
and knows all of the rules about horror
movies we see these rules referenced
Time and Time Again by the killer on the
phone and that leads us to see Randy as
a prime suspect I'm the first to
admitted If This Were a scary movie I'd
be the the prime suspect however there
may be someone who is an equally big
horror buff and that is Stu moer in fact
there are a couple of clues that link
him to the video store just as much as
Randy the store has two posters on
display the one on the left is a poster
for the 1993 film mother's boys starring
Jam Lee Curtis Stu is a huge fan of jam
Lee all the videos he rents for his
party have her in them Terror train
promite how come Jam Lee Curtis is in
all of his movies she's the scream and
with a set of lungs like that she should
be on the right is a poster for the band
green jelly this same poster can be seen
when Sydney runs into Stu's room to
escape ghost phase so I think it just
serves as a link to show us that Stu
probably spends more time than we'd
expect at the video store this point in
the movie there are a few innuendos as
well Tatum tells Sydney that her
intimacy issues will thought out with
time as she removes a case of popsicles
from the freezer this basically tells us
that Sydney's getting ready to lose her
virginity then there's this mem worthy
moment our eyes are drawn to a certain
part of a frame which of course is
Tatum's lungs then our eyes are drawn to
another part of the frame this spiral
pattern just kind of draws you in it's
like a hypnosis even though we don't see
her having sex we know Tatum Falls
victim to rule number one because her
death occurs when she gets stuck in the
pet door in the garage and she's unable
to get out because her tits and cheeks
are too big also the song playing when
she enters the garage is Drop Dead
Gorgeous by Republica scream was doing
death Omen songs four years before final
destination came out that night Sydney
does end up giving up the vCard to Billy
and Ghost Face breaks in and appears to
kill him but obviously we know it was
just corn syrup the way stew cleans off
the knife is very interesting to me the
emotion almost kind of resembles taking
off a condom and for Sydney it comes
immediately as a post-sex act and Stu
later admits that he did have a thing
for Sydney which he responds to by
pushing the TV onto him and saying in
your
dreams it's kind of a Karma moment
because Stu was the one to laugh in ry's
face when he asked if he might have a
chance with Sydney after everything
we've been through it's only fitting
that the action ends with one last meta
horror trip this is the moment when the
supposedly dead killer comes back back
to life for one last
scare not in my movie what do you mean
not in my movie it literally just
happened before we can end this video
there is one more thing I want to talk
[Music]
about the big surprise in Scream that
again like the camera work and writing
choices that I brought up in this video
uses our horror genre expectations
against us is the fact that there are
two killers instead of the usual one
that we get in most slasher movies the
clues were there all along in the Casey
Becker scene one Ghost Face breaks into
the house and runs straight to the front
door we don't know why at the time but
it was to let his accomplice inside you
can actually spot that the door is now
open when Casey's parents get home at
the fountain Stu explains to Sydney how
you got someone and Billy makes eye
contact with him and says hey it's
called tact you we assume that he's
standing up for his girlfriend but he
might actually be trying to shut stew up
before he says too much and gives them
away this might be obvious but Sydney
first suspected Billy when she sees the
cell phone fall out of his pocket if he
has a cell phone why does he need to
come sneak through the window to talk to
her then there are multiple instances of
Billy just acting sus like when Sydney
admits that she doesn't think that he's
guilty and he keeps trying to convince
her you still think it's me no I I don't
it's just somebody was there some
someone tried to kill me I know I know I
know the cops said I scared him away it
wasn't me Sid I know he called me again
last night at Tatum's house you see
couldn't have been me I was in jail and
this is obviously him trying too hard to
drive home the point that the second
Ghost Face call exonerates him steu does
a similar thing at the fountain I didn't
kill anybody nobody said you did then at
the school there are a couple of
pranksters who run around in ghost face
masks and they find themselves sitting
in the principal's office one is wearing
a blue flannel with a white t-shirt
underneath which is what Billy wears to
the party and the other is wearing a
muted long sleeve shirt not the same
color but very similar in style to what
Stu has on at the party now I want you
to look very closely right
here
had to get that one last scare
in throughout Scream 2 we see a few
glimpses of the movie stab which is
essentially the in Universe version of
Scream one each character's stab
counterpart is played by a known actor
from our world and in the case of Sydney
that actress is Tori Spelling which is
playing off a joke from the original
screen hey so just think if they make a
movie about you who's going to play you
I see you as a young Meg gry myself
thanks to we with my Lu Kory spelling at
one point it suggested that the new
killer is trying to make an in real life
sequel to The Happenings in Woodsboro
from the year before and Scream 2
consequently features many scenes that
call back to the original to learn the
meaning behind this graffiti stick
around to the end of this video and I'll
be back when you guys start talking
about something a little more sa by the
Bell welcome to things you missed I am
Zach Morris as discussed in the last
episode Scream one was a satire on
horror movies so naturally Scream 2
satirizes sequels in fact it openly
acknowledges that they're usually
inferior to the original so what's the
deal here did they intentionally make
scream too an inferior movie in the
movie premiere scene Moren gets Flack
from her fellow movie goers when she
loudly encourages the character on
screen to use some common sense Scream 2
features previously intelligent
characters doing things that make you
want to scream at the television like
splitting up with a killer in the
vicinity backing up against a window and
going back to unmask someone when you
should just run the way I see it
someone's have to make a sequel you know
cash in all the movie murder hoop says
Randy as he enjoys his product placement
let's get in to the things you
missed in the first scream I talked
about how the movie started by pulling a
page from Alfred Hitchcock Psycho by
killing off its poster girl this time
the poster features two more big stars
Jada pinket and Sarah Michelle Geller
Jada's character Moren is the second to
die after her boyfriend just like Casey
and Sarah's character CeCe is third also
speaking of pulling a page from psycho
the opening scene of stab as aart where
Casey goes into the shower the shot of
the tap turning on is the same shot from
psycho the rest of the scene is pretty
accurate to what we saw in screen
including the conversation which begs
the question how would the creators of
stab know what transpired that night
unless one of the participants was
actually still alive Scream one used
Halloween as a template a movie that
everybody knows and can understand how
it's being sazed but Scream 2 doesn't
really offer an equivalent however stab
acts as an in Universe standing for
Scream one and we've seen something
similar in the Halloween Fran in
Halloween 3 we see that the original
Halloween is just a movie in that
Universe Halloween 3 is also a famously
panned sequel but other than that there
aren't really any similarities scream
had become famous and there were already
movies in production trying to imitate
it so the challenge was for Scream 2 to
try to be the best imitator while the
first scream made its gimmick apparent
by having the killers quiz Casey on
scary movies while being in a scary
movie Scream 2 tells us that these
horror movie fans are about to be in a
movie of Their Own by using screen
Direction stab Casey is seen running to
the left towards a door and then we cut
to Phil going through a door himself
this link is the director's way of
telling us that he's about to be a
victim too we hear the song read right
hand by Nick Cave in the Bad Seeds twice
in this movie in the first one it played
during the curfew lockup montage and in
two we hear it right as stab as
beginning and as the Delta Lambda Zeta
party disperses perhaps another link to
tell us that the movie is leaking into
reality there are a lot of instances
where things from Scream 2 fill the role
for material from the first one for
example Sydney's college mascot is the
wild cats a less specific version of the
Panthers which was her High School
mascot it plays into the idea that we
have copycat Killers just like how the
initial three victims share a name with
the first three victims in Woodsboro
Sydney once again gets unwanted
attention from the Press because of her
past the scene where CeCe has attacked
at her sorority house is just like the
scene of Sydney being attacked at her
actual home and just like Scream one a
ghost face pops out from a closet by the
stairs I wonder if the fact that he
hides Under the Stairs is a West Craven
reference cce's immediate reaction is to
then run up the stairs just like high
school Sydney said that she would some
stupid killer stalking some big breasted
girl who can't act who's always running
up this stairs when she should be going
out the front door the ice cream scene
is the new video store scene in the
video store Scene Randy directly
determines who one of the killers is by
accusing Billy who fires back by asking
how do we know you're not the Killer and
Randy admits that If This Were a scary
movie he would in fact be a prime
suspect this time he correctly
identifies Mickey as one of the killers
the freaky Tarantino film student but
also concedes that he would likely be a
suspect on the same ground but if he's a
suspect so am I worth noting in the
scene he's also kind of on the right
track when it comes to the second killer
he brings up Mrs VOR as proof that the
killer could be a female like Mrs
Vorhees from Friday the 13th the Killer
is the mom of another killer ry's other
suspect is Gail weathers that's what
reporters do Dey they stage the news
he's got the right idea but he's got the
wrong reporter history repeats itself
later in the movie when Gail and Dewey
team up and Gail makes an important
Discovery while they're hooking up in
the original it's Neil Prescott's car
and in the sequel It's Mickey's tapes
the Killer is once again behind Randy
look behind you Dewey gets stabbed in
the back again Gail blocks the door to
the recording studio so that ghost face
can only reach in and FL it's like
Sydney in her room Mickey reveals
himself as the killer using a familiar
line surprise Sydney just like Stu did
during the last 20 minutes of scream
surprise Sydney at the end Sydney buries
one in Mrs lum's forehead just like she
had with her son and it all ends with
cotton foreshadowing the next stab film
I'll tell you one thing don't make a
hell of a movie but there is one Easter
egg that even I wouldn't have found if
not for this retrospective
documentary
[Music]
I'm sure you noticed the way that ghost
face wipes off the knife in Scream to
it's a signature move established by Stu
in the first movie I wanted to bring it
up though because in my video on the
first film I tried to as I do figure out
what the subtext behind this might be
however in the 2011 retrospective still
screaming danne Farwell the stunt actor
in that scene offers a simpler
explanation it's a direct cut to me
running through the hall with a clean
Knife West just SP thought for 2 seconds
he said well wipe the knife off on
camera another thing I talked about in
my first video was relevant Cameo
appearances and those seem to have been
given special attention here in 1997
Director of Photography Peter dumming
plays the popcorn boy screenwriter Kevin
Williamson is the interviewer on current
edition I never would have noticed this
on my own but Matthew Lillard who plays
stew and scream used 2% of his power to
make a background Cameo at the party
scene which thankfully for me he brought
up in the retrospective otherwise I
would never have known it was him you
know one day I was just hanging out and
they like who in the back of the party
scene and director Wes Craven makes
another appearance this time as a doctor
at the hospital scene that one I
actually found out about from a fan site
which is coincidentally also called
still screaming the best Cameo though is
this one from Lev shriber dog what a boy
there are a bunch of other cameos but on
things you missed I'm only interested in
ones that have some kind of significance
or something to do with the movie after
a film class discussion on sequels and
imitators of movie Killers Gail brushes
off the idea of audience safety being
important are you kidding me it' be
stupid to pull this movie all this Free
Press they're going to have huge numbers
this weekend you either die a hero or
live long enough to see yourself become
the villain despite this movie's concept
being a takeoff of horror sequels we
aren't bombarded with movie references
like we were in screen instead there's
another theme that the finale centers
itself around theater Sydney is a
theater major and has a prominent role
in the production of Agamemnon which is
advertised all over the
campus candra is one of the great tragic
Visionaries of literature you saw it all
coming the wars the murder the madness
she knew she was cursed it was her fate
and she embraced it this might be a
comparison between two unlikely subjects
to be pair horror movie final girls and
Greek mythology one of the things that
audiences tend to find ridiculous about
sequels is the fact that the same
characters get themselves into trouble
again it always seems like a huge
coincidence that only exists to extend
the franchise that's why in a lot of
long running franchises there's some
kind of curse that keeps the killer
coming back again and again the
character Sydney plays in Agamemnon is
Cassandra who is literally cursed by the
Greek god Apollo in the case of scream
it's obviously not like a magic curse
but rather that Sydney is cursed by the
publicity of the horrible things that
have happened to her I do think it's
significant that their whole culture on
campus revolves around these sororities
or as they are sometimes called Greek
life in the car crash scene there's some
graffiti of Greek letters representing
the sorority where the party took place
earlier Delta Lambda Zeta along with
some text in English that says stab this
but the Greek letters are crossed out in
red and this is the scene where that
sorority's pledge hi gets herself Dred
off by Mickey the movie's climax takes
place on the stage where the fall of
Troy set is still up this is where Ghost
Face attacks her on more than one
occasion the Greek versus the Trojan so
to speak at the end she actually uses
her Greek letters given to her by her
boyfriend to protect her to attack
Mickey and ultimately get away the play
that she's in is agamon which like stab
is the first chapter of a Trilogy scream
was also a Trilogy from 2000 to
2011 Empire Strikes Back better story
improv the effect not a sequel part of a
Trilogy completely pled in Scream I
think I pointed out like 20 different
Nightmare on Elm Street references but
Scream 2 seems to have just one when
cotton is arrested by Sydney's
bodyguards in the library we see a book
called our dreaming mind which deals
with the science of sleep and dreams
much like how Nancy visits a sleep
disorder clinic to try to fix her Freddy
to to try to fix her Freddy Freeman
problem to try to fix her Freddy Kruger
problem for a minute I also thought this
was Freddy's iconic sweater in Sid's
dorm room but when I actually compared
the two I realized that they're not the
same I had the same thing happen in
Sid's room when I analyzed the first
scream I thought this was Chucky's
sweater but eventually realized that the
colors don't match scream to has a girl
that looks kind of like Chucky but again
the colors don't match as I did for the
first movie I want to wrap up by talking
about some of the evidence about who the
killers are some of which you may have
missed first up we've got cce's sorority
house where we can confirm once again
that there are two killers because you
can still hear one Ghost Face talking on
the phone as the other sneaks through
the front door in the background During
certain Chase scenes we hear Ghost Face
grunting sometimes it sounds
male and at other times the sound is
female but when speaking on the phone we
can't make this determination because of
the voice changer when Sydney gets a
ghost face call from Deborah salt AKA
Mrs Lumis at the sorority house she
hears
this hello Sydney remember me suggesting
that it's someone from Sydney's past
like her late ex-boyfriend's Mom and
from a filmmaking standpoint when you
make a sequel you have to include enough
information so that audiences who
haven't seen the first one can still
keep up we only see two scenes from
staff the opening and this scene which
reminds us that Billy's mom left him and
his dad the only reason to cut away from
the scene that we're in and focus on
that part is if that information is
going to be important somehow like if
Billy's mom were to for example come
back Deborah also suspiciously manages
to get to the scene of the crime at the
sari house where CeCe was attacked and
at the film school where Dewey was
attacked before anyone else maybe
because she was already there but the
strongest evidence is actually evidence
for Mickey being guilty in class he
argues with the idea that sequels can be
better than the original of course he
would say that the Windsor murders are
his sequel to The Woodsboro murders you
know I knew this was coming I knew this
wasn't Over You Are Not Alone soon yeah
he would know that this was coming
because he was responsible the most
damning evidence though is the fact that
he always has his video camera when Dey
and Gale go to study their tapes they
can see each of the crime scenes were
recorded from Ghost Face's point of view
the only issue is that he wasn't the one
projecting these tapes he must have
given them to Mrs Lumis at some point
because he was planning on getting
caught so he could use the trial to try
to blame the movies for his actions okay
I take back what I said the most damning
evidence against Mickey is the fact that
we can see him right here through the
eyeholes of the ghost face mask stream 2
was famously Rewritten during production
because the ending leaked on the
internet so the fact that we have all of
these setups is kind of impressive we're
mostly all in agreement that scream one
is superior and I think the idea that
the sequels villain could just be
switched out like that is kind of a
testament to it being a weaker story
however with all of that being said I
guess cotton was going to be one of the
villains originally and I'm sort of glad
that that didn't happen because his
Redemption at the end is one of the best
parts and it sets us up for Scream 3 if
you're a Kevin Smith fan you may already
be familiar with Jay and Silent Bob's
cameo in Scream 3 but you might not know
the backstory behind it Jay and Silent
Bob are a pair of characters that first
appeared in Kevin Smith's 1994 movie
Clerks which is prominently displayed at
the video store in the original screen
Jay and Bob would become recurring
characters who show up in many Kevin
Smith films that are part of his VIIs
universe and as a thank you for the free
advertising and scream Kevin Smith and
scream director Wes Craven decided to
exchange cameos in each other's movies
so Jay and Silent Bob show up in Scream
3 and the following Year Wes shows up in
Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back where he
plays Wes Craven the director of Scream
4 a decade before he would actually
create Scream 4 in addition to that
cotton weary's apartment in the opening
of Scream 3 contains a copy of Chasing
Amy which is also part of the VIIs
Universe the scene with Jane Silent Bob
also contains a couple other cameos
which are pretty much only findable
thanks to the retrospective documentary
still screaming which points out a cameo
from West Craven as the man with the
video camera and scream 3's casting
director Lisa Beach as the tour guide to
learn how Scream 3 may have had a second
killer who died before being revealed
stick around to the end of this
[Music]
video in Scream movies don't create
psychos movies make psychos more
creative in Scream 2 movies are a
scapegoat for someone who is planning to
be a killer Scream 3 reverses this and
has the killer make the movie creating
his own lore every step of the way
welcome to things you missed wanting to
capitalize on the train created by
Scream 1 and 2 producers decided to go
ahead without screenwriter Kevin
Williamson by replacing him with Aaron
Krueger really the creator of a
nightmare in El street is working with a
guy named Krueger stage name you should
talk Judy
jurer Sydney Prescott has become a
crisis hotline counselor and she also
takes on a stage name of sorts going by
Laura to her callers she's unknowingly
following in the footsteps of her mother
who used the name aren Reynolds while
working in Hollywood there's a running
theme of pseudonyms in Scream 3 most of
our main characters are the actors who
are just as likely to respond to their
character names as their actual names to
the point that it becomes kind of a joke
not Sydney Sydney like I'm Gil and she's
Gil obviously it's more than just a joke
though it's important to the plots
because Roman's changing of his last
name to Bridger is what helps disguise
his true identity as Sydney's brother
and the killer let's get in to the
things you
missed as with screams 1 and two the
opening shows the slaying of a couple
only this time we recognize one of the
victims it's cotton Wei and his
girlfriend cotton is complaining that
he's only given a small cameo in stab 3
which is basically his experience in
Scream through despite being a big part
of the second movie they kill him off
right away in this one one of the
criticisms of turning scream into a
franchise was that it would become the
very thing that the original scream was
s rizing and we see this intentionally
or not intentionally in Scream 3's
opening in the last film stab one
attempted to recreate the opening of
Scream the death of Casey Becker but
certain things are embellished for
Hollywood like how they add a shower
scene which seems to have no purpose
other than showing a little Little Skin
So scream 3's opening literally does
that in the form of Cotton's girlfriend
getting out of the shower there's even a
shot of Christine's towel dropping by
her feet very similar to Casey's
bathrobe and stab the whole shower
thing's been done vertigo hello it's not
vertigo it's psycho as we've discussed
many times on the show then Christine
even channels her inner Casey Becker
herself when she kicks Ghost Face To Get
Away scream 2's opening was all about
the stab movie premiere so there's a
slight nod to that as well when cotton
is frantically driving home he nearly
hits a bus with a stab to advertisement
on the back this next one might not be a
reference this might just be cotton
being entirely focused on saving his
girlfriend but he leaves his car door
open as he goes inside much like Bob
Sims in Halloween who is probably also
focused on one thing entirely as you
know if you've seen scream Halloween is
basically considered the big one and
it's referenced all the time but not
that much in Scream 3 although there is
one part where Sydney hears her mother's
voice telling her that she'll protect
her from the boogeyman the boogeyman is
a pseudonym for Michael Meers in the
Halloween films Ghostface tries to
pressure cotton into revealing the
location of Sydney Prescott before
offing him and then then we see Sydney
living a secluded life with her dog by
her door there's a fall of Troy poster
advertising the place she was in in
college Agamemnon does that mean she
actually went through with being in the
play after defeating Mickey and Debbie
on its stage that's dedication she also
continues to wear the Greek letters
given to her by her boyfriend when the
murders were happening in the last movie
can you really blame her he was the best
guy she ever dated the next character we
meet is Gail weathers who's giving a
speech about being a journalist lady a
woman in the crowd is wearing a number
81 Jersey not many people know this but
Scream 1996 was not the first or last
slasher movie to be called screen the
original was a 1981 film I have not seen
it but according to the letter box
rating it is not very good this scene
also has the best extra this lady is
just really in Gail's speech this speech
is part of a lecture series called FW
bester lecture series faces of
Journalism named after the movies art
Department coordinator Claudia bestor
just like the last two movies Sydney is
at home when she sees bad news on the TV
that involves her and her past as we're
first introduced to Sunrise Studio where
most of the movie takes place we hear
the song red right hand by Nick Cave in
the B seeds which by this point is more
or less the Scream theme song this is
our fourth time hearing it and the end
credits would be the fifth although that
one is a special Scream 3 version meant
to close out the trilogy stab 3's
subtitle is return to Woodsboro and this
phrase keeps finding new meaning
throughout the movie it's actually a
leftover from Kevin Williamson's
original outline for the script that he
planned after writing Scream 2 but most
of it was not used for what would become
Scream 3 we would symbolically return to
Woodsboro immediately because they're
shooting on the Woodsboro set Sydney
would return to Woodsboro when she's
later chased through the set later still
the focus of the story is brought back
to Woodsboro when we learn new
information about the motivations of
Billy and Stu and the movie would end
with everybody returning to Woodsboro or
at least what appears to be Woodsboro to
join Sydney at her secluded home with
the first scene on the Woodsboro set
contains more depth than what meets the
[Music]
eye when we meet Roman the director of
stab 3 he's busy making a case for
keeping the production going after
Cotton's death death hey hire more
Security hire the National Guard just
don't kill the movie which is funny
because he literally would kill the
movie at least for the time being by
killing everyone in it he's seen arguing
with the studio executive played by
Roger Corman who tells him that violence
in cinema is kind of a no no right now
which is also a little joke because
Roger Corman is a well-known horror
producer and director he literally made
movies such as KN of the blood Beast a
bucket of blood bloody Mama Battle of
blood Island blood bath a remake of a
bucket of blood but his concern over
gory movies in 1999 was very relevant
because stab 3 is the in Universe
standin for Scream 3 and Scream 3 was
going through the same problems at this
time thanks to the Coline Massacre the
worst high school shooting of the
Millennium the Coline Massacre was
carried out by two High School seniors
and that's really the only similarity to
scream that exists but that didn't stop
people who were already against horror
movies everybody that didn't like horror
films that was in a position of power
came after the studios Columbine
happened in April 1999 Scream 3 started
shooting in July so there was a lot of
pressure from the studio to limit the
gore which is why we see less of it in
this movie according to Matthew Lillard
he was already paid to appear in Scream
3 as the returning villain Stu mocker
but Coline put an end to those plans Wes
Craven attempted to make sure that the
cultural context was not forgotten by
sneaking in this article about Coline
into the scene where Sydney looks
through her file at the police station
the other articles in this file are just
nonsense look at this one the local
police chief the first official
commissioned by the city with the search
committed in the name of the parents the
shadowy suspect faces 121 charges of
murder kidnapping arms smuggling fraud
and theft his plea is that he hadn't
committed these offenses said the
parents attorney we will find the Megan
at all cost when Gil that is the real
Gale shows up on set she's hit by a wave
of dreadful
familiarity Deja vood her misuse of the
term Deja Vu right outside of Sydney's
house calls back to Sydney's own misuse
of the phrase in Scream one The
Nostalgia does not end there though
because the new gaale AKA Jennifer is
dressed more like the old G but what
happens next is not all old and familiar
gaale runs into Dewey who has become an
adviser for the movie when the two met
in Scream 2 dwey was upset with how Gail
portrayed him in her book now dwey has
turned the tables on her and Gail is
upset about how he's portraying her in
stab 3 in my previous scream analysis
videos I pointed out west Craven's
Easter eggs to his other major horror
franchise A Nightmare on Elm Street we
don't really get much of that in the
third one but there is a tiny nightmare
scene involving Sydney where she sees
her dead mother come to the window for
being honest though the reference points
a lot more to Salem's line than it does
towards Freddy Krueger the next day
Sarah Darling who plays the character
candy in stab has a meeting with Roman
at the production office I'm candy the
chick who gets killed second I'm only in
two scenes like cotton gripes about his
character the complaint about her screen
time could also apply to her role in
Scream 3 she's only in two scenes
there's also another one toone parallel
later where the police mention that
there are three versions of the stab 3
script in order to try to keep the
ending off the internet the exact same
approach was used for Scream 3 and then
there's the romance between Dewey and
gal this time rather than art imitating
life life would imitate art these two
got married for real Z's right before
they started shooting anyway during the
line reading Roman goes off script and
then claims there's a new version it's
not just a new script it's a new movie
what movie my movie although we don't
know it yet she's speaking to the real
Roman and he's telling the truth by
killing the people involved in stab 3
he's creating the lore for stab 3 he's
creating his movie Candi is the
successor to Tatum and scream and her
death closely resembles tatums Ghostface
chases her into the prop room where
among all of the movie props is the
fridge remember Tatum went to the garage
to get drinks from the fridge she's
punched through a door where she's left
hanging on her stomach and this is where
ghost face gets her she dies in the
exact same position that Tatum died in
in the pet flly while Gail and Dewey are
out to lunch to discuss their past
relationship Gail emphasizes the
importance of leaving him alone to go
onto the sequel to 60 Minutes claiming
that she could have been the next Diane
Sawyer it's a bit of a scream to
reference Diane Sawyer was the
journalist that cotton most wanted to be
interviewed by to gained Fame back on
the movie Set we have maybe our most
obvious set of crew reference Easter
eggs yet on the director's chairs yes
they are called that this one's for
Peter Deming the Director of Photography
This one belongs to Sheila Wald drone
the script supervisor and there's one
for Bruce Allen Miller the production
designer that evening the cast gathers
for a depressing rap party at Jennifer's
house where the killing continues with
her security guard and Roman continues
to quote unquote write his movie by
literally sending in script Pages
telling them what to do via facts uh if
you don't know what facts is look it up
the house blows up taking out Tom aka
the new Dewey and the old Gale punches
the new Gil in the face this is yet
another twst on the scream tradition of
Miss weathers getting a face full of
Knuckles in each film the characters end
up at the police station where they're
finally reunited with Sydney one nice
detail at the station is the display of
movie posters and books about film it's
like Randy suggested in Scream one that
the cops should study movies to save
time speaking of Randy he makes his
return in the form of a postmortem video
message which he would use to
communicate a few new horror movie
rules true TR trilogies are all about
going back to the beginning and
discovering something that wasn't true
from the get-go Godfather Jedi all
revealed something that we thought was
true that wasn't true this was not his
first time referencing the original Star
Wars Trilogy we saw him mention it in
Scream to and it wouldn't be long before
it came up again the two gals meet the
sunrise Studios archist who is played by
Carrie fiser AKA Princess Leia in Star
Wars I was up for Princess Leia I was
this close so who gets it the one who
sleeps with George Lucas also shares
something in common with Sydney her
Trilogy also involves the surprise twist
where she discovers that someone is her
brother they pull out the file for Moren
Prescott who at the time was going by
Reena Reynolds at the bottom of her
resume we can see that she started her
acting career in theater just as her
daughter would go on to do one of the
plays that she was in was even called I
want to scream so they've got this whole
little family involved in the dramatic
art it's Moren with her acting in plays
and horror films Roman the director and
Sydney the live performer if candi's
death was a call back to Tatum this
scene where Sydney is chased through the
movie Set is is a repeat of her own
scene in Scream right down to her
screwing herself by locking herself in
with ghost face at the front door
there's also another similarity in
Scream she calls the police using this
program on her computer and Dey
immediately shows up at her door in
Scream three she literally just yells
out for Dey and he comes running because
he's already at the studio the cops show
up and we see this one new cop named Jay
West this is the last crew reference
Easter egg it's a reference to the
assistant production coordinator John
Burton West after discovering Morin
worked in the movies Dewey and the gals
confronts the producer John Milton who
basically tells them that he held these
parties back in the day where industry
bigwigs took advantage of actresses and
he basically turned a blind eye to this
illegal activity if you followed the
entertainment industry recently this
might sound familiar in 2018 film
producer Harvey Weinstein was arrested
as many allegations came out against him
some of which dated back to the 1970s
the very same time period that John
Milton claimed to have these parties
could this be a coincidence maybe not
from my understanding Weinstein got away
with this for as long as he did because
he targeted smalltime actresses they did
not take legal action because they were
afraid they be blacklisted from the
industry since Harvey had many contacts
with all of Hollywood for example two
actresses up for parts in The Lord of
the Rings lost their roles simply
because Weinstein told Peter Jackson
that they were a nightmare to work with
that's the kind of influence that he had
but with the Advent of the internet and
social media the victims were able to
discovered that they were not the only
ones there were a lot like a whole lot
so they came together knowing that they
couldn't all be blacklisted the point of
all this is is that while they didn't
get him arrested for many years there
were rumors about Weinstein's Behavior
so it's very possible that Wes Craven
may have known about these rumors and
pulled the biggest power move of all
time by putting a Harvey Weinstein
character in his movie which by the way
was produced by Bob and Harvey Weinstein
but unlike these relatively unknown
actresses Wes Craven had already made it
in Hollywood Weinstein couldn't really
do anything to him and besides he was
already nearing the end of his career
and despite being the executive producer
Harvey Weinstein couldn't really stop
Wes from using Scream 3 to make this
indirect accusation because if he
ordered Wes to change the John Milton
scene he's just going to look guilty
according to the film's editor Patrick
lucier in an article on slate the only
notes to come from the Weinstein
Brothers at all came from Harvey's
brother Bob and he just had a note about
the ending which I'll get back to you
later in this video so Wes had his boss
backed into a corner where he could not
give any notes it's got to be one of the
most legendary moves that Wes has ever
made if in fact this is not a total huge
coincidence Hollywood is full of
criminals whose careers are flourishing
I'm not a criminal yeah I don't think it
is and to further add to the suspicion
some of the accusers are connected to
the scream franchise rousan Arquette is
the real life sister of d D AR cats
doing and Rose Macwan who plays Tatum
and scream is the onscreen sister of
David rcats Angelina Jolie potentially
has two characters named after her in
Scream 3 Jennifer Jolie and Angelina
Tyler who says this I did not that pig
Milton to get a leading role just to die
here with second rate celebrities like
you do the movie's climax takes place at
a mansion party where Roman's birthday
is to be celebrated while we don't
realize it at the time I don't think
it's any coincidence that Roman puts his
plan into action on his birthday the day
that he became morvine Prescott's
bastard child the party splits up to
explore the mansion and Jennifer finds
herself stuck in a passage with a ghost
face she sees Dewey on the other side of
the soundproof glass barrier and
struggles to get his attention this is
the same situation that the real Gil was
in in Scream 2 when she was unable to
communicate with him in the recording
studio there's another repeat of a
Scream 2 situation in the basement when
Roman is knocked out after falling down
the stairs but his body blocks the only
exit this is like when Sydney had to
climb over Mickey to escape the crashed
car Roman uses his capture of G and
Dewey to lure Sydney back into the house
house but she's prepared and greets him
with her hidden gun unfortunately for
her this is the one time that she didn't
deliver a follow-up shot to the head and
it comes back to bite her the final
confrontation takes place in the secret
screening room where Roman was
theoretically conceived after revealing
himself as the killer there are a couple
more parallels to scream One the
bringing out of a gagged victim and
Roman cocking his head just like ghost
face when he first pinned down Sydney at
her dad's house after he is defeated
we're treated to an epilog we see a
Sydney essentially let her guard down
for the first time since that fateful
phone call a few years ago then we see
detective kin Cade the cop from La who
apparently came back with her he's
holding a bowl of popcorn and says
they're about to start a movie so the
scream Trilogy ends just as it began
with popcorn and a movie I personally
think that this was supposed to be the
end of the series by comparing the last
ever scream scene to the first ever we
see the changed state of the world
before and after the defeat of Roman the
driving force behind all of the bad
things that happened to Sydney in the
1990s however having only one killer
doesn't follow the scream franchise
formula and there could be one more
villain from the production of stab 3
who is get to be taken care
of earlier in this video I mentioned two
darker topics Weinstein and Coline I
stated that Wes Craven and his editor
only received one note on the film and
it came from the innocent of the two
brothers Bob Weinstein his idea was to
remove the second ghost face to just
focus on Roman the reason for this or at
least one of the reasons may have been
teased in the film remember the scene
where the producers are having the
discussion with Roman about the future
of the film emphasizing that stringed
instruments in cinema are a big deal
right now a big reason for that was
Coline so the shooting may have also
been part of the reason that they moved
away from the initial concept of having
two killers the accomplice was going to
be Angelina Tyler the woman who was set
to play the fictional version of Sydney
in stab 3 you can still see remnants of
this storyline in the film in fact some
fans believe that Angelina is still
canonically the sixth ghost face and she
was killed before she ever got the
chance to reveal herself her story is
that she won the role in a talent search
but we later found out that she did this
by Sleeping with the producer you got to
be praying this movie keeps going of
course I am but not at the expense of
people's lives you either die a hero or
live there are three main sequences that
make Angelina look guilty the first is
shortly after Jennifer's house explode
she briefly disappears and comes down
the hill well after everyone else almost
like she knew where to jump to avoid
taking fall damage this allows her to
completely miss the altercation with
Roman Dewey asks her about her
whereabouts but she never actually
answers the question God Tom was in the
house then there's the bathroom scene
which by the way way is set up exactly
like the school bathroom scene in Scream
one Sydney discovers her seemingly
changing into the ghost face costume but
Angelina plays it off as her wanting to
take props as souvenirs now that the
movie is shut down but what if this is
actually her getting caught and being
the actress that she is talking her way
out of it this could also be the reason
that Roman decides to kill her off he
probably figured that Sydney knew she
was guilty and it was better to get rid
of her before she had the chance to be
arrested and interrogated where she
would possibly give them both away he
knew Sydney wouldn't accuse her
immediately though because she wouldn't
want to repeat of cotton Wei on her
ience who went to jail because he was
wrongfully Accused by Sid when she
wasn't quite 100% sure so I think
Angelina makes up an excuse quickly
scurries away and goes into the Sound
Stage to finish putting on the ghost
face costume when Sydney goes into the
movie Set version of her room there are
clearly two killers here someone is
pushing on the door and then 3 seconds
later ghost faces all the way on the
other side of the room and behind her in
the window I think the one in the window
is Angelina because the shoes we see
during the struggle are the exact same
ones that Sydney noticed under the
bathroom stall when the lights go on we
get a better look at Angelina wearing
these shoes with a black skirt I I don't
I don't know the terminology for this
piece of clothing but the loose black
fabric could easily help her blend into
the Ghostface cloak and the third
sequence where she looks guilty is
Roman's birthday party sure they appear
to be using the buddy system for safety
but Roman and Angelina are each
oneon-one with a victim Dewey and Gil
also poke around and find a ghost face
mask cell phone and voice changer in a
closet but these are not Romans because
he clearly has his own I can understand
having a backup costume but why have a
second voice changer Angelina was
supposed to be with Tyson but she
appears and Roman faces death just like
Billy did in hindsight he's probably the
one that taught Billy how to make that
Hollywood level corn syrup mixture
during the big reveal Roman even
suggests that he gave Billy pointers on
being a killer such as having a partner
to sell out once you got caught this
means that Roman probably also had a
disposable partner when we last see
Angelina she's frantically trying to
leave the house could it be that at this
point she knows that Roman is done with
her and she's now just fearing for her
life or is this part of the ACT we don't
actually see her die she just gets
stabbed in the shoulder and dragged out
of view it's awfully inconclusive exive
for a scream character to go out like
this maybe scream seven will feature Stu
and Angelina as Ghostface Killers
personally I don't think there's a ton
of evidence to suggest that she's alive
though it's definitely a small
possibility but I am of the belief that
she was Roman's accomplice and there's a
ton of evidence to support that let me
know your thoughts on Angelina in the
comments Scream 3 was marketed as the
last Scream the Final Act the very end
so join me next time on things you
missed as I cover scree form also known
as scream form scre form welcomed us
back to Woods High School it doesn't
look exactly the same but this could
technically be a different entrance and
this could just be a different part of
the building but one aspect that is
definitely a new addition which you
might have missed is this bus dedicated
to the late principal Arthur Henry who
is one of the victims in Scream one
here's a little bit of a better look
from a behind the-scenes photo for other
references that you might not have
noticed like the movie props featured in
the background of stabon stick around to
the end of this
video
welcome to things you missed I am don't
look at my tits I have a mind Morris and
if you remember that reference it
probably hasn't been long since you last
watched scree form and I actually think
this is one of the most warranted
examples of putting a number in the
title in place of a letter in a movie
like s7n or 13 Ghosts there's no real
reason for it other than style but since
this movie serves as a satire of horror
movie remakes most of which have the
same title as the original inserting the
number four allows you to read it as
just screen while it's still
differentiating that this is the four
movie which makes it all the more
disappointing that they didn't follow
suit with Scream 2022 by calling it five
cream let's get in to the things you
missed being a remake this one opens
exactly the same way that the original
did with a teen girl receiving a phone
call Sherry and shudy are trying to pick
a movie and we see the blue screen on
the TV something that I talked about
when I covered the original screen which
represents the idea that a movie is
about to begin not only for us the
audience but also the characters who are
somewhat aware that they're living
through a movie however this is the
first movie to take place well after the
others it's set in 2010 so the new
horror reference points for the young
characters are naughty's horror like saw
and Final Destination saw in particular
seems to have the biggest influence on
Scream 4 it's the movie that Sherry
chooses for the movie night and the
color grade takes after the saw look for
example look at the first outdoor scene
and how the bloom resembles the look of
the public execution Trout from Saw 7 or
for a better idea of exactly how the
look of this movie differs from the
previous ones try comparing the stab
footage from Scream 2 to to that of the
fourth movie there are also a few scenes
that seem to have Saw's imprint on them
Olivia encounters her massed attacker
hiding in her closet just like Adam from
Saw Rebecca is ambushed in an empty
parking garage just like Dr Gordon from
saw one of the side characters is Robbie
Mercer who's played by Eric nudson he
was Daniel Matthews and saw too and both
of them know a lot about cameras stab is
now a seven movie series just like how
saw was at the time stabian is held in
an abandoned Barn this was well before
jigsaw the Saw movie that's set in an
abandoned barn but Gail's coming across
this creepy pigh head next to the these
Rusty gears looks like something right
out of the original saw Saga or as some
of you suggested on my saw videos The
Saga the opening of scree form also
serves as a mission statement about what
we should expect for this movie and that
is to expect the
unexpected the unexpected is the new
cliche modern audiences get Savvy to the
rules of The Originals so the reversals
become the new standard the intro does
this with its false openings first we
see two girls get killed turns out that
just stabs six then we see some
medicinema commentary from our new
characters Al predictable there's no
element of surprise you can see
everything
coming but that just turns out to be
stab 7even so we're seeing firsthand how
the filmmakers are now actively trying
to do what the audience doesn't expect
in the decade since stab 3 and this of
course also applies to our movie Scream
for scre form so after those two false
intros we meet our real intro characters
Marne Cooper and Jenny Randall Marne
does share a last name with CC Cooper
from Scream 2 but they probably aren't
related despite their shared eye and
hair color actually more interested in
her first name Marne because it brings
to mind the 1964 Alfred Hitchcock film
being one of the most important figures
in the horror genre Hitchcock has
already been the subject of several
homages in the scream franchise like
Billy Lumis sharing a name with Sam
Lumis from psycho the shower shot from
psycho being in stab and one of the
actresses in Scream 3 incorrectly
identifying it as a reference to vertigo
among others in the classroom or Cinema
Club is held you can spot a vertigo
poster on the chalkboard there's a
lesson about the pro structure of
Hitchcock's rear window and Kirby's room
has a rear window poster as well may not
be the only Hitchcock namesake Sydney
has a publicist named Rebecca which
could be an homage to Hitchcock's 1940
film Rebecca and the police officer
Perkins is actually named Anthony
Perkins we hear his partner call him
that Anthony Perkins Anthony Perkins is
the actor who played Norman baits in
Psycho the rest of the intro sequence
features a lot of fun homages to the
scream franchise like Ghostface trying
to tell Jenny to think of him as her
director you're in my movie you got a
fun part so don't blow it the last
villain literally was the director of
stab 3 Marne is sent crashing through
the glass door I'll ask Steve orth from
Scream but you you're the dumb blonde
with the big tits we'll have some fun
with you before you die and just like
Sydney predicted in the first scream she
makes the mistake of running up the
stairs rather than out the front door
she ends up going up to the attic like
Sydney did to escape ghost face at Stu's
house and then eventually to the garage
where her Escape is spoiled by the
garage door just like Tatum in screen
Dewey is woken up by his
[Music]
ringtone
the song is Axel F from the soundtrack
of Beverly Hills Cop and Dewey is also a
cop again he's now the sheriff of
Woodsboro also of note this song has
been remade many times by the likes of
technocop clock and yes Crazy
Frog soon we meet the next generation of
Woodsboro high school students it seems
that Kirby knows who the Killer is
without actually knowing who the Killer
is before you get in the car you have to
promise not to kill me there's a similar
foreshadowing Moment Like This later
when officer hos is doing a crossword
puzzle and asked Perkins for a
four-letter word for courage
uh guts it would not be long after that
when Olivia's guts would be ripped out
by ghost face this event is also
foreshadowed by the Chinese takeout
boxes that have a red splatter design
but before we get there we would check
in on the current state of Gail Riley
whose office plays host to a few more
things you
[Music]
missed each new character in the fourth
installment of scream is a spiritual
successor to one of the characters from
the original scream which is why it's a
satire of horror movie remakes like a
remake you have new actors playing old
roles Jill is the new Sydney Prescott a
high school student thrust into danger
due to the attack of her family member
Trevor is Billy Lumis the boyfriend who
becomes a major suspect Kirby is Randy
Meeks the biggest horror film buff of
the friend group and walking knowledge
database Olivia is Tatum Riley the
attractive and popular girl who dies way
too early Charlie is Stu moer the easily
peer pressured friend Robbie Mercer is
Kenny the camera guy and Rebecca is Gail
weathers the media she even makes the
comparison between Dewey and Barney F
just like Gail did back in Scream
to page 32 Deputy Dewey filled the room
with his Barney fish presence thank you
just wait Barney F I'm running an event
here speaking of gal she's now writing a
work of fiction after Penning the book
Trilogy that became the basis for the
stab movies and we can see them right
here the Woodsboro murders College
Terror and Hollywood horror it seems
that she also wrote other stories about
a Ghost Face Killer because there's this
additional book face returns which we
get a better look at later in Jill's
room this is probably the basis for the
fictional stab movies 4 through 7 after
news that the killings have started
again breaks we see the Woodsboro police
station and if you pause you can see the
kq6 van wording by in the foreground
this is the same station that Gail
worked for back in Scream one where the
van was parked outside during stocker's
party we also see the Channel 6
microphone appear a couple of times
throughout the movie Rebecca is
celebrating the news of the two girls
being butchered and she calls it a
Payday the media sensationalizing the
crimes has been a theme that has run
through each of the scream movie so far
in the first and second films it's the
TV news media in the third it's the
Hollywood film industry and now we're
seeing it happen in publishing there
would also be another angle present to
this in Scream 4 social media Robbie
gets involved as essentially what we
would Now call the IRL streamer and the
killers are recording all of their kills
which Jill plans to use to help frame
Trevor and Charlie and anticipates that
the footage will go viral and Garner her
more attention however she fails so this
part never pans out later in the movie
Rebecca tries to convince Sydney to sign
a new book deal you're a victim for life
so embrace it and this is another aspect
of the social commentary about the media
Rebecca doesn't understand the point of
Sydney's book it's about her journey to
no longer be the victim Jill on the
other hand is on a journey to become the
victim how do you think people become
famous anymore you don't have to achieve
anything you just got to have up
happened to you she's an extreme
example of someone with what we would
Now call victim mentality like the
original scream social commentary about
sensationalizing violence in the news
and scream three commentary about
inappropriate relations in Hollywood
scree form's take on victim mentality
has only become more relevant over the
years as more and more people try to
invent a scenario where they're
perceived as having been wronged with
the intention of going viral the my
experience with blank Trope on social
media has become as cliche as the
slasher movies that Randy idolized in
Scream he had me unfollow all of them
which to me was really weird and I
didn't like it but anyway when Rebecca
meets Gail Gail tells her that she is
Gail Riley now she's been married to Dey
for 10 years to which Rebecca is
surprised it always seemed like more of
a movie romance than a real one because
it was a movie and in real life you two
never
be in my Scream 3 video I mentioned that
Dewey and Gail's marriage was one of the
many plot elements inspired by real life
because David arat and Courtney Cox
actually got married now they had
actually been married for 10 years and
like in the movie their relationship was
in trouble they separated in real life
in 2010 the same year that this movie is
set the trouble in their on-screen
marriage is exemplified that evening at
the house in a line that also serves as
another call back to that Dey and Gil
scen from Scream too this this time
instead of Dewey quoting a specific page
from Gail's book He's quoting Sydney's
book in regards to his
marriage just when you think things
can't get any
worse sometimes they don't sometimes
they get
better out of darkness by Sydney
Prescott page 220 later in the evening
after Ghost Face comes for Olivia Sydney
tries to get into the Morris household
to save her and she does so by throwing
a potted plant through the window Sydney
has always been seen as the slasher
successor to Lori Strode from Halloween
with her story even running parallel to
Lor's in Scream one and now we've got
her throwing a potted plant at a house
like Lori in Halloween as always the
movie is packed with Halloween
references when Sydney makes a guest
appearance at the cinema Club Robbie
Hypes up her Presence by comparing her
to the actresses that starred in
Halloween and The Exorcist beond Jam Le
Curtis forget Linda Blair I mean this is
the ultimate which is also kind of its
own joke because they both appear in
Scream one the Cinema Club holds their
party stabon at an abandoned Farmhouse
much like the party in Halloween 5 but
if you look closer there's a four sale
sign outside inside the farm that says
Roberts realy Roberts refers to Sydney's
mom's side of the family her mother was
Morin Roberts before getting married and
Sydney's aunt is Kate Roberts she is the
realtor that this sign is referring to
earlier drafts of the script make
mention of her profession Kate takes
Sydney in while she's back in Woodsboro
we can assume that cydney's dad moved
away or died because he's not in the
movie so Sydney is staying with a
realtor who happens to be selling the
location of stabon and this is another
similarity she has to Lori Strode who
after losing her parents is taken in by
the Strode family and her new adopted
father is a realtor who is selling a
house the Meers house which was the
location of a more literal stabon with
Sydney being part of the older
generation now she takes responsibility
for the kid's safety towards the end she
instructs Jill to hide under a bed and
then makes it look as if she's helped
her Escape off the balcony this is very
similar to Lor's strategy in Halloween
of course there's one line where Sid is
made out to look less like Lori and more
like her brother you just won't die will
you who are you Michael Fu Myers the
last Halloween reference I want to bring
up is this poster seen in the classroom
where Cinema Club is tell if you've seen
Rob Zombies Halloween 2 you know that it
is not a remake of Halloween 2 Rob
Zombies Halloween 1 is a remake of the
original Halloween however Rob Zombies
Halloween 2 goes off in its own strange
Direction I'm guessing this was likely a
hint about what the plans were for the
scream franchise in January 2010
screenwriter Kevin Williamson who had
returned after an absence in Scream 3
stated that he was contracted to make
Scream 4 and Scream 5 however the fourth
movie underperformed at the box office
director West Craven got brain cancer
and the fifth installment had to be put
on the Shelf save that one for a rainy
decade but as long as we're talking
about the meta of scree form I've got to
mention what is perhaps the most meta
thing in the whole
[Music]
franchise remember that cop character
Anthony Perkins well not only is he
named after a psycho actor but he also
appeared in Scary Movie 3 scary movie is
a parody of scream and scream is a
satire of the horror genre if you've
kept up with my scre scream things you
missed series you already know that the
first scream contained many references
to slasher movies including Wes Craven's
own work so Scream 4 focuses on movies
that were remade the new version of the
video store scene is the cinema club
scene where we see a whole bunch of
movie posters like this one The Hills
Have Eyes this checks both boxes it was
directed by Wes Craven and it received a
remake in 2006 if you're really paying
attention you'll also notice the poster
for The People Under the Stairs a 1991
West Craven production before his death
Craven planned to remake this but never
quite got around to it there's Al a
poster for George Romero's dawn of the
de it was remade in 2004 the thing is a
remake of the thing from another world
from 1951 you may notice the poster on
the left is not a horror movie it's a
film called Zack and Mary Make a Porno
this is actually a continuation of a
series of Easter eggs between Wes Craven
and Kevin Smith I talked about this in
Greater detail in my Scream 3 episode
but the two directors have been
exchanging cameos and Easter eggs in
their movies since the original screen
if you look around the classroom you'll
also see that the Cinema Club are big
fans of the stab franchise you can see
the stab poster right here and the stab
3 poster in the back corner an
interesting note here is the tagline for
stab 3 is Hollywood horror which means
this is not the same movie we saw being
shot in Scream 3 whose tagline was
Return to Woodsboro it seems that since
all of the cast was killed the studio
decided to make stab three about that
rather than trying to recast for return
to Woodsboro little did they know the
story would return to Woodsboro all on
its own behind the Shelf is the stab
five poster and the stab 6 poster but
that's really only just the beginning of
the display of their stab fandom we see
much more that night at the stabon where
there a of background details that you
may have missed here's a girl dressed as
Casey Becker posing with a decoration of
the gutted Casey Becker which you can
see more of behind the crowd right here
another display shows Tatum Riley
hanging out of the garage flap many of
the attendees are wearing costumes of
scream and stab characters something
that is very accurate if you've ever
been to a screening these two guys in
the audience are both dressed as Dewey
and one of them even has a mustache hat
there's another Casey Becker on the left
a lot of the kids have Woodsboro High
School letterman jackets like Casey's
boyfriend Steve orth but then again
those are their actual high school
jackets so I won't count that one but I
will count this couple dressed as Gail
and Dewey Gail in her green news dress
and Dewey in his uniform this party is
all about the stab movies come on how
meta can you get how what can you get I
don't know I heard him say it Gail
places cameras around the party much
like she did in Scream so that she can
watch from her vehicle in fact one of
the cameras is right beneath the movie
screen just as the surveillance camera
in Scream was placed under Stu's
television now you're probably wondering
are there differences between the
version of stab that we saw in Scream 2
and what we see here in Scream 4 so I
cut both films apart and lined them both
up and the answer is yes there are a lot
of differences enough to make a whole
video about it which I plan on doing but
for this video I'm only going to talk
about the ones that are interesting in
Scream 4 we see this card at the
beginning a Robert Rodriguez film this
sort of qualifies as a crew reference
Easter egg because Robert Rodriguez was
brought in to direct the stab footage
for Scream 2 after lining up all of the
cut points there's an interesting
synchronization that occurs which is
that Gail gets stabbed at the same time
as Casey in stab which in Scream 2
occurs at the same time Moren was
stabbed inside of the movie theater just
thought that was kind of cool before
being attacked Gail holds her camera by
her waist looking behind her
unintentionally recreating the moment
from Scream where the characters in the
news van see Ghost Face sneaking up
behind Randy behind you kid Randy this
time it's Dewey concerned about gil g
Dale behind you this is more than just a
nostalgic callback though it also sets
up a scene later where Robbie puts on
his headset backwards we're expecting
ghost face to appear behind him so it's
more of a surprise when the killer ends
up being right in front of him just
another example of this movie's mission
to do the unexpected that also includes
the film's ending we're led to believe
that it'll end at the party just like
the original but this is what the
reboots do they they they won up the
original ending the Woodsboro murders
ended at a party so in the remake the
part is the false ending new rules
however this also ends up being a false
ending the true ending takes place at
the hospital just as there were two
false openings there were also two false
endings this is something that happens
in the Halloween remake the original
ends at the doyle house but the Remake
continues on and ends at the Myers house
there probably other examples of remakes
in the 2000s doing this though so in
this case we have the quote unquote
remake continuing on past the original
whereas in the '90s if you wanted to
continue on past the original you had to
watch Scream 2 which contains a scene of
a character named CCE watching the movie
no Fatu and getting killed shortly after
for this reason I find it fitting that
Kirby's room displays a nose Fatu poster
but who knows if there is any actual
meaning behind this choice I mean it's
kind of a stretch on my part to make
that connection however I am convinced
that the wardrobe choices were
definitely done for a reason I talked
about how each character in reform
represents one of the characters from
screen however after the reveal of The
Killers all of those roles are
reassigned Jill is now Billy The
Mastermind behind the murders Charlie is
still Stu the accomplice hoping to vent
his romantic frustrations with a knife
and Trevor is now Neil Prescott the tied
up victim who is going to be framed so
it's no mistake that Jill is wearing a
blue plaid shirt just like what Billy
wore at the party and Trevor is wearing
this exact outfit that Neil was captured
in back in 1996 other callbacks include
Sydney escaping off the roof Charlie
being tied to a chair like St or Kirby
being quizzed on horror movies like
Casey Becker and of course this iconic
line hello Sydney surprised surprise
Sydney surprise Sydney I imagine she's
getting tired of hearing that in my
personal opinion scre form was one of
the more satisfying surprises though
which makes all of the clues about the
Killer's identities all the more
impressive a on re-watching the movie I
noticed that while Jill and Charlie
pretend that they aren't particularly
close they do sit next to each other in
class and Jill is the only one to not
take out her phone when everyone's
getting alerts about Jenny and Marne
though I'm not sure why she doesn't just
at least pretend to be interested on a
somewhat related note fellow Zach and
fellow horror Creator Zach Cherry
pointed out in his video that Sydney
doesn't appear to have a cell phone in
the movie she receives calls on Jill's
cell phone and the Roberts landline and
after arriving at Kirby's she borrows
Jill's phone to place an outgoing call
to Dewey to plead for help this is
probably because Sydney is is tired of
all the prank calls and doesn't want to
give any future copycat Killers a means
of contacting her it's a nice touch Mr
Cherry also attributes a lot of the
kills to Charlie which many were
surprised by but I personally think it
kind of makes sense Jill would have
wanted to set it up that way because of
the fact that they're recording all of
the kills and the fact that she's
secretly planning to frame Charlie as
one of the killers alongside Trevor it
stands the reason that the police would
probably study these videos and take
note of the Killer's Heights and broad
shoulders Charlie might also be the most
forceful Ghost Face we've seen check
this
out
when I analyzed Scream one I mentioned
that the poster in Stu's room matched a
poster displayed in the video store and
that this linked his character to the
movie Obsessed killer a similar tactic
is used here Jill's room is filled with
Clues this farewell Republic poster and
this uh I don't know reverse Griffin are
both posters seen hanging at the cinema
Club I will mention the possibility that
there's actually no meaning behind that
they could have just reused the posters
and hope that nobody would notice
because this war of the world's poster
in Jill's room also shows up in her
English class I can't think of any
reason they'd want to link Jill to her
English classroom so it's very possible
that the art department just ran out of
posters and I'm just looking for things
that aren't there but at the very least
we can conclude that Jill is more
interested in horror movies and serial
killers than she likes to let on from
her American Werewolf in London poster
to her Edgar Allen poster to her Gail
weathers books books on psychology and
serial killers and even her Fallout Boy
poster this particular one is the cover
for their single I don't care whose
chorus matches her Mo for the movie I
don't care what you think as long as
it's about this might be more halfen
stance but this is also off their album
fully Ado which is French for madness in
pairs a term that could probably be used
to describe each pair of the Ghostface
Killers I love this album and I'd love
to talk more about it but this is not a
music analysis channel so let's get back
to scre form after Olivia is killed
Charlie comes out of the dark to attack
Sydney and Jill and Jill receives a cut
on her forearm the same spot that Dereck
got cut in Scream too no struggle he
just cut you and ran away you're lucky
he didn't kill you yeah it's awfully
convenient say what nothing
it's just a shame he got away so easily
it's just a shame you got there too late
of course Derrick ended up not being
guilty so dwey would probably want to
avoid making any similar accusations
about Jill when Sydney speaks to Jill
the following night she has what she
thinks is a bonding moment with her
cousin you know when people say I know
how you feel but you know they're just
saying that because they really have no
freaking idea how you feel I know how
you feel I love that line because in
reality Sydney has no idea how Jill
feels because she doesn't suspect her of
being the killer it's like the sticker
on the door of the Cinema Club says not
your usual suspects Jill claims she
could never handle the attention of
being the surviving victim when in fact
that's exactly what she wants even if
her 15 minutes of fame really is only 15
minutes and finally at Kirby's
Afterparty Trevor shows up unexpectedly
and just walks right in because the door
is unlocked by the way Kirby with
everything that's going on right now you
probably shouldn't leave that unlocked
Sorry Charlie is not worried about
locking the door because he knows
there's no threats he and Jill are both
in the room already scree form would be
the final Legacy of director Wes Craven
but his creation would live on without
him after yet another 11-year Gap with
Scream 2022 most scream fans already
know about how Scream 2022 paid tribute
to Wes Craven the director of Screams 1-
4 by naming a character after him having
a house party dedicated to that
character after his death and repeating
the words for Wes as the first thing we
see in the end credits what you might
not have noticed was the hidden meaning
behind Wes's phone number the 707 is
just the area code for the part of
Northern California where Woods would be
located and all of the Woodsboro
characters have this area code but 1939
refers to the year that Wes Craven was
born we actually see Craven's birthday
come up again later during the YouTube
video about stab 2021 the channel
subscriber count is
8219 39 which could be read as 82 1939
under the American date format of month
day year this represents August 2 1939
the day West Craven was born this page
contains a lot of other Easter eggs
including other hidden dates in the
numbers to learn about many classic
cameos secrets on tattoos and meanings
behind names on cell phones stick around
to the end of this
video when I heard there was going to be
a new Scream movie I was hoping the
franchise would come back to tackle the
phenomenon of rals like Halloween 2018
Jurassic world and Candyman 2021 then I
started watching scream 2022 and
realized oh yeah scre form already was a
requel also I generally don't really
like rals but what I do like about them
is that they're basically Easter nest
what do I mean by that a nest is
somewhere where you might find a lot of
eggs in this case Easter eggs as in the
hidden secrets found in contemporary
media one of my favorite things to
analyze on things you missed so let's
get in to the things you
[Music]
miss each entry in the scream franchise
serves as a satire of the horror genre
and sometimes of media franchises as a
whole as you are very aware of if you've
seen my previous videos on Scream Scream
2 Scream 3 and scre form there were a
few franchises that theyd like to use as
a blueprint of Swords first there's
Halloween the movie shown in the first
scream which served as an example of
horror movie rules then there's Star
Wars which was most heavily discussed in
Scream 3 when the characters were trying
to figure out the rules for trilogies
finally there's scream which also exists
in Universe where it's known as the stab
franchise so many things that happen in
Scream 2022 from bigger plot points to
little moments are callbacks to things
that have happened in the scream
franchise which is also fitting for a
requel because these movies often share
the concept of it's happening again so
for the third time in franchise history
it starts with a phone ringing then a
female picking it up and speaking to an
anonymous caller then she starts playing
with a knife block and then she gets
attacked by ghost face and she kicks her
attacker in an attempt to escape then in
a parallel to scream One a group of
friends discusses the attack the next
day while sitting outside of Woodsboro
High School while eating grapes we find
out boyfriend and girlfriend Chad and
Liv aren't sleeping together like Sydney
and Billy in Scream and an announcement
from the high School principal cancels
classes just like in Scream but did you
notice who the new principal
was attention cancers a reminder that
all classes and school activities are
canell tomorrow due to public safety
concerns according to executive producer
Chad Vella in this interview with Bloody
Disgusting that was a voice Cameo from
Drew Barrymore who is known for playing
Casey Becker in the original screen
there are many other voice cameos
presence in the movie most of them can
be heard during Amber's party the first
comes from Matthew Lillard who played
Stu in
SC fitting considering that this is
Stu's old house several Cameo voices
overlap when the guests make a toast to
the character Wes hey to
Wes the article states that many people
who knew Wes Craven contributed voices
for this line including three scream
actors Henry Winkler who played
principal hry Adam Brody who played
officer hos in scree form and Hayden
pettier who played Kirby co-director
Tyler Gillette added that Jamie Kennedy
who played Randy in the original scream
Trilogy contributed did this line
somebody's goofy ass dad is kicking us
out which he actually says right while
his character is delivering his lines in
stab which is playing on the TV where we
can see another Cameo co-director Matt
banelli opin revealed that he plays the
onscreen Michael Myers in the movie
within the movie within the movie maybe
we should stop calling it scream and
start calling it shk because this thing
has got layers speaking of Halloween
there's also a reference to its director
my name is Samantha Carpenter this is an
homage to Halloween director John
Carpenter or possibly Wes Carpenter duck
other said you're starting to sound like
some West Carpenter flickers the new
directors for scream 2022 went a little
bit crazy with references to West
Craven's body of work starting with
Sydney Prescott's address it's Sydney
Prescott and she lived on El although it
was mentioned in the original script I
don't think that Sid's street address
was ever brought up in the first movie
but Elm is a reference to Elm Street
from West Craven's famous franchise and
Nightmare on Elm Street we actually see
the Elm Street intersection later when
Sam and Richie roll into town then when
we're reintroduced to Dewey you can see
his list of cell phone cont conts if you
pause at the right moment one of his
contacts is Christy which is probably a
reference to Christy Parker From A
Nightmare on Elm Street 3 and four
christe is played by Patricia Rats the
real life sister of dey's actor David
rats also of note in dey's list of
contacts is B Misa which is a nod to
Brad MSA the owner of horror movie news
website Bloody Disgusting which may
explain why they have all these
exclusive interviews with the directors
and producers which I keep referencing
during the YouTube scene later on the
related videos panel also suggests an
upload from the Bloody Disgusting
Channel another exclusive interview but
we'll get to that later under B MSA
keeping up with the theme of Internet
horror personalities is Mr Morris that's
me Zach Morris you might be thinking no
that's just the father of Olivia Morris
from scre form but no she doesn't have a
father your mom home she's boyfriends so
it must be talking about me if dead meat
gets to be in it I get to be in it too
damn it another one of Dewey's contacts
is Judy which is probably just Judy
Hicks his old Deputy at the police
station I was thinking it's kind of a
shame that he never got with her after
he split up with Gil but who knows maybe
he actually did actually now that I
think about it she must have already had
a kid by the time she was hitting on
Dewey in scre form so that's weird we
actually see her list of contacts too
and you can spot more West Craven
related homages Tina G represents Tina
Gray from the original nightmare in Elm
Streets Leroy is a character from
Craven's 1991 film The People Under the
Stairs Nancy T of course is Nancy
Thompson the main girl from A Nightmare
on Elm Street B Adams is Brandon Adams
the actor who played Fool in The People
Under the Stairs under her son there are
three deputies listed Deputy Vincent and
Deputy Farney are actual characters in
the movie Deputy Keith is not I'm
guessing this is a crew reference Easter
egg because the movie's production
designer is named Chad Keith for all the
West Craven related Easter eggs it seems
like there's only one Easter egg related
to Kevin Williamson the screenwriter of
Screams one 2 and four it comes when
terara is in the hospital watching an
episode of Dawson's Creek this is season
1 episode 11 the scare which was written
by Williamson and the episode itself is
kind of a spoof of the original screen
like I said there are a lot of layers to
this we're not done with with the West
Craven Easter eggs though I'll be
continuing to analyze those and Richie's
big slip up that would have given him
away as the killer if only his
girlfriend had
[Music]
noticed throughout the movie we see a
couple of memorials to pass characters
Dewey has a box dedicated to his sister
Tatum and Martha has a home theater
dedicated to her brother Randy on the
mantle there's also a photo of a movie
theater Marquee with three movies
playing a nightmare on Elm Streets The
Hills Have Eyes and Last House on the
Left all West Craven directed films Sam
Carpenter is essentially the new Sydney
Prescott in this movie much like
Sydney's father in the original we
learned Sam's mom is out of town both of
their mothers are cheaters both
characters have some psychological
issues caused by Billy Lumis Sydney
because Billy killed her father and Sam
because Billy is her real father
throughout the series I've discussed how
Sydney shares similarities with
Halloween's protagonist Lorie Strode Sam
takes after her as well Lori was a
babysitter in the original Halloween and
it turns out that Sam has some
experience in child care as well these
are Chad and Mindy the Twins and Wes I
used to babysit them all the first
victim to die this time around is Vince
who we eventually learned to be
stocker's nephew in a requel everyone
has to have some dumb reason to be
related to Legacy characters there's
also a little clue about this in the
opening scene where Tara looks up the
cast of the original stab on her phone
there's a new addition here a cast
member who wasn't specified back in
Scream 2 and that is Vince vaugh playing
the role of Stu mocker so the names
Vince and Stu are kind of linked from
the very beginning there's also a detail
on the hood of Vince's car not only a
movie detail but like an actual car
detail the words six-pack are written
there perhaps a hint that we'll be
seeing a sixth movie also this guy
parked in front of him is parked in
front of a fire hydrant come on man the
cops are right there Vince also has a
Jason tattoo this is probably a red
herring making the audience think that
he might be the killer considering the
line that Richie said
earlier and I got to make sure we don't
get sliced up by some lunatic who suff
frer the 13th and thought you know what
that Jason guy he's got some pretty
solid ideas of course Vince and ends up
being a victim not a killer during his
death scene we hear the song red right
hand which appeared in every Scream
movie besides scree form so it's good to
see it back on rotation here Ghost Face
actually takes out Vince with his own
switchblade not the usual Ghostface
knife I'm guessing this is just another
red herring though to make it look like
Vince was somehow connected finally
after like 35 minutes we see Sydney
Prescott she's a runner now which seems
like a reasonable hobby after a lifetime
of being chased by Psychopaths and she
finally owns a cell phone she never had
one in scre form but seeing as how that
didn't prevent her from being targeted
by the next ghost face she probably
decided to just cave in and get one
Dewey mentions that she's married to
someone named Mark there is a mark in
the scream franchise that is detective
Mark cancade the cop from Scream 3 who
weirdly came back to her house and
watched movies with the trio at the end
one of the Bloody Disgusting articles
that I mentioned earlier addresses this
the executive producer confirms that
Sydney's husband is indeed Mark conc I
can't say this fully makes sense to me
because where was he in scree form and
where is he now and why is Sydney's name
still Sydney Prescott I'm guessing she
still wanted to take take advantage of
the notoriety of her name for her career
as an author the original scream
featured a scene known as the video
store scene where Randy speculates on
who the killer might be every subsequent
sequel so far has had its own version of
the video store scene this time it's the
Randy Meeks Memorial Theater scene and
Mindy the new Randy fills the gang in on
her ideas about who might be guilty at
one point during the scene Dewey refers
to Stu moer as a real Looney Tune this
might be a reference to the fact that
Stu was in the 2003 movie Looney Tunes
back in Action where he plays himself
Matthew Lillard arguing with Shaggy also
voiced by Lillard about the quality of
his performance in Scooby-Doo the movie
a scene probably meta enough to be in a
Scream movie if we're being honest in
the background there's a vertigo poster
this is now the third Scream movie in a
row to reference vertigo starting with
Sarah's line in Scream 3 and this poster
in scree form vertigo is directed by
Alfred Hitchcock who borderline invented
the slasher genre with his movie Psycho
Psycho has been referenced in every
Scream movie and that continues here
with this poster Amber imitating the
psycho soundtrack as she gestures her
knife
one of the ghost face Killers even
directly cites the movie This Time
Around ever seen the movie Psycho and
then we cut directly to this shots where
Wes is taking a shower it's the same
camera angle used in the shower scene
from psycho and subsequently the shower
scene from stab in the second screen the
next character to die is Wes as I
mentioned he gets out of the shower and
explores downstairs in the kitchen
there's a note from his mom Wes lemon
squares in the fridge love Mom this is a
call back to Judy's famous lemon squares
which she made for Dewey in scree form
Sheriff
you're not cheating on your wife if you
eat my lemon square the ones that Gail
found disgusting your lemon squares
taste like speaking of whom she returns
to the story by stepping out of this kq6
news van it's the same station that Gail
worked for in Scream but ever since then
she's worked other jobs such as
upto-date 60 Minutes 2 total
entertainment and she even went rogue
for a while seeing her back at her
original station is exactly the choice
you'd expect from a requel looking not
to upset the status quo at this point
Dewey and Gail are divorced an event we
already saw saw brewing in scree form
but it sounds like their divorce went
exactly like their breakup in between
Scream 2 and Scream 3 Gail gets an
important job opportunity in a big city
and the two can't make it work long
distance Dewey belongs in Woodsboro Gail
belongs in a big City Reporter job once
again history seems to be repeating
itself with these two despite Gail being
back in her old job the underlying theme
about the media and its effect on real
world violence is not as present in the
new scream like it was in the first four
movies we do get a little bit of
discourse about the entertainment news
industry at the end where Richie seems
to imply that he was driven to the brink
partly by the media blaming fans for the
poor reception of the new stab movie but
I see that as just one aspect of a
bigger conversation around this idea of
toxic fandom so what is toxic fandom is
it real is it a problem should we be
worried about it the most agreed upon
definition reads when a person believes
that they have the only correct way of
appreciating certain content they will
attack other fans and disagree with them
even when they're discussing a topic
that the toxic fan knows little about or
has only heard from secondhand sources I
will add that it seems that toxic fandom
has also become a buzzword used by
journalists or salty creators to try to
get clicks and sway a narrative for
example let's say a new movie from a
popular franchise comes out and it's bad
those involved might soon be crying
about toxic fandom to try to make all
criticisms look invalid I'm sure there
are fans in those cases who dislike that
new movie merely because it does not fit
their belief about what the franchise
should be like but that does not make
the entire fandom toxic and it shouldn't
invalidate good criticisms based on the
quality of the work so is it a problem
should we be worried about it at the end
of the day it's all just online
discourse there's no reason to take it
that seriously I feel like it can offer
a unique perspective here as someone who
is both a fan and a Creator as a fan I
try to separate my bias from my critique
for example I don't really like the
concept of Toy Story 4 because I think
the third was such a perfect ending but
I don't think it's a bad movie I mean I
recognize that it's wellmade for what it
is but when something is bad I think
it's important to be vocal about it in a
constructive way as a fan it shows that
you care and a good Creator will take
quality criticism into account for
future work as a Creator you have to be
able to separate good criticism from
comments by those who are never going to
like your content in the first place and
that brings us to my favorite cameo in
the movie The Dead Meat Cameo and this
web page has more hidden content than
you could possibly
[Music]
[Applause]
imagine for those unaware the couple
behind the film fils Channel which richy
can be seen watching on his laptop is
actually James aice and his wife Chelsea
the host of YouTube's biggest horror
movie channel dead meat who we can
actually see a real upload from in the
recommended bar on the right it struck
me as strange that they would use a
madeup brand for their Channel because
this is a Scream movie all the movies
and shows referen tend to be real movies
and shows from our world The Only
Exception being stab which is a standin
for a real franchise the scream
franchise I figured I might as well go
straight to the source on this one
because I can so I asked James why that
might be this is what he had to say
mostly because we're being a-holes in it
it's a parody of more toxic YouTube
channels that cover movies it's not
meant to be us or dead means and I think
that's a great answer because it fits
right in with what I was saying earlier
about toxic fandom these film fails
characters aren't really saying anything
constructive about the movie they're
basically just pouting that it's not the
stab that they know and are comfortable
with and when I think more about it
there is actually precedent for this
Sunrise Studios doesn't exist it was
just a parody of a predatory movie
studio kq6 doesn't exist either it's a
parody of bloodthirsty journalism film
fails more specifically seems to be a
parody of YouTube channels that
screeched about Star Wars The Last Jedi
in 2017 judging by that dead meat upload
on the side Ryan Johnson on Reinventing
staff Ryan Johnson was the director of
that heavily debated Star Wars title and
often the target of vital from fans and
content creators I'm sure there are many
people that would like you to believe
that the Last Jedi was divisive or
controversial but if you actually look
at the ratings most people just found it
to be very average I already talked
about film fail subscriber count being
Wes Craven's birthday but the view count
is also significant it has 122,000 196
views 12296 December 20th 1996 was the
release date of the original screen then
there's the like to dislike ratio it has
1,117 likes and 20 dislikes 11720 or
November 17th 20120 was the day that
production wrapped on Scream 2022 thanks
to Richie for using the return YouTube
dislike extension so we could see that
one on the side there's a video from
bloody disgusting's YouTube channel that
I mentioned earlier it's titled
interview with Woodsboro Survivor Kirby
Reid Kirby was a major character in the
fourth movie and up until now we were
led to believe that she didn't make it
so this is actually big news the fourth
video is called not stab join the stab
head Army and # redo stab 2021 and it's
uploaded by a channel called stab head
there's a bit of a story behind this one
so grab some popcorn dreadit is the name
of a horror movie community on Reddit
Mindy actually mentions it when she's
explaining the fan contempt for stab
AIDS you go on forchan and dread it all
they're talking about is how stab a
pissed on their childhood to promote
scream 2022 is release the team behind
the movie held an ask me anything
session on dreadit one user named stab
head asked did any of the actors go
above and beyond to prepare for their
roles there were reply was we were
meeting with Jack to talk about his
character and he told us that he had
created a Reddit account under the name
stab head to wait a minutes we love you
jack Quaid necessary information Jack
Quaid is the actor who played Richie the
second Ghost Face Killer the account
shows him commenting on topics like
Halloween The Last Jedi and of course
scream so the way I see it stab head is
actually Richie's online Persona he was
the one to create this Channel and
upload this video Amber even mentions
during the finale that she met Richie on
the stab subreddits under the stab head
upload there's one more video of
importance did the real life Stu mocker
survive as I mentioned in my Scream 3
video the original plan for that movie
was to have Stu return as the villain
but since this was right after Coline
producers decided it was not the best
idea to have a high school Revenge
Seeker right now but this video title
suggests that maybe having Stu return in
the future is not yet out of the
question if he's alive then he's been in
prison for about 25 years now although
Stu himself isn't in this movie his
actor has yet another vocal Cameo here
as the voice of the new silverface ghost
face that is L one of the common
complaints about the new ghost face in
stab 2021 is his new weapon a
flamethrower ironically the new ghost
face in this movie ends up getting
herself lit on fire the link to film's
merch store is aao.org Spanish for until
the fire which could also be a clue
about Amber's F when she has her one
last scare moment at the end she's
covered in Burn scars very reminiscent
of Freddy Krueger you can bets that this
was by Design about Midway through the
film the deaths of Judy and Wes are
discovered and Sam realizes that her
sister may be in trouble at the hospital
so she gives Richie a quick call to
check on her and hears an unexpected
voice on the other
line hello
Samantha Richie can't come to the phone
right
now he's finding out what happens to
people who stick their noses in business
that doesn't concern them it reminds me
of Jigsaw re-recording Daniel Matthew's
voicemail greeting in sawu you've
reached Daniel's phone he's not in right
now I love a good horror movie voicemail
greeting if this was the fourth movie
which had a lot lot of Saw references
this might be an intentional nod to saw
but this is the fifth movie which
focuses more on the so-called elevated
horror genre for example tera's favorite
movie is the Boba due and she begs to be
quizzed on the gems of the mid to late
10 ask me about it follows ask me about
hereditary ask me about The Witch she's
got really good taste she describes
elevated horror as being scary but with
complex emotional and thematic
underpinnings not just cheesy jump
scares which Richie as a fan of stab
isn't thrilled with that sounds kind of
boring to me and in the home theater
scene stab's slasher stylings and
elevated horror are painted to be
opposites a major reason cited for fans
not liking the newest stab movie was
crammed in social commentary so Richie
was upset that his favorite franchise
was trying to ride the trendy wave of
elevated horror and set out to craft his
own entry more in line with the original
by doing a requel the huge gaping
question that leaves is isn't that
exactly what Jill already tried to do
and yes it is the only difference was
their motivations Jill did it for fame
but Richie and Amber just wanted to
motivate the creation of another stab
movie it doesn't seem like being the
star was as important to them even if we
are to give them the benefit of the
doubt and say that these killers are an
homage to scream for rather than copying
it there are still a couple of other
necessary details to make it make sense
which I didn't fully realize in my first
Vie the first is that there is no stab
movie based on scree form if there was
Richie and Amber probably wouldn't have
felt the need to make a new one at the
time of scre form there are seven stab
movies and in this movie there's only
one new one hence the # redo stab 8 then
there's the fact that the original scam
and really all of the Scream movies do
feature some kind of social commentary
which I've taken time to discuss in each
of my things you miss videos so why
would Richie be upset about the new stab
having social commentary this is because
in the scream Universe the stab movies
are considered non-fiction nobody is
making up the plot so nothing that
happens qualifies as commentary because
that's how you make a great stab movie
Sam based on actual events and this ties
right back into the theme of toxic
fandom Richie believes that each stab
movie must be like the original that's
why there's so many repeated elements
from from the original screen like when
terara is trying to defend herself at
the
hospital God damn it sheit me with the
look at must have been thrilling for
Richie to be reliving events from the
original sta you've got to find me first
you pansy mama's
boy me with a Fone in some cases lines
are nearly lifted directly from a
previous movie you think you're still
the star this isn't a movie it
will be this isn't a movie movie
no but it will be the final Act features
plenty more references some of which you
might have noticed but you probably
missed this tiny detail which was the
reason that Mindy was able to survive
where others did not welcome to act
three
[Music]
run before we get to the Final Act let's
talk about Dewey his fatal mistake is
shooting Amber's bulletproof armor
rather than hitting her in the head he
realizes it a little too late in Scream
three he makes the same mistake with
Roman but Sydney is there to remind him
to aim for the head this time she isn't
and Dewey pays the price given Dewey's
ability to survive seemingly fatal blows
in the past I wasn't convinced that he
was really done for this time we've seen
this scene before however the more I
look at it the more I think he might
really be gone this time he's being
taken to the coroner this time not the
ambulance I doubt the coroner would be
called unless some medical professional
was really sure that he was dead do we
had to die to make it real to show that
this wasn't just some cash in
run-of-the-mill Sequel well this is
awkward it also fits the blueprint of a
requel when the cast is talking about
reels Mindy brings up Star Wars the
Force awakens as an example there will
be spoilers for Star Wars the Force
awakens here so if you don't want to
hear them skip forward to the next
chapter the force awakens is all about
passing the torch to a new set of
characters Luke Leia and Han are passing
it off to Ray Finn and po this is
accentuated by the death of a Legacy
character Han on solo so scream 2022 is
doing the same here by killing off Dewey
as the Torches passed from Sydney dwey
and Gail to Sam terara Mindy and Chad
and just as the force awakens brought
back familiar locations like the
Millennium Falcon and the Star Killer
which is basically the death star scream
2022 brings back the mocker household
which plays host to another party which
is probably the most tasteless thing
ever considering it's supposedly
supposed to honor their friend West but
it looks like a typical college party I
guess it's kind of fitting though
considering the existence of this movie
here we see a few more callbacks the
basement fridge is the new garage fridge
not many people have basements in
California Richie is wearing a blue
plaid shirt like former Woodsboro
Killers Billy Lumis and Jill Roberts
when Sydney arrives the first door she
checks behind is the same one she hid
behind when she doned the ghost face
mask in the original scream perhaps the
most obvious repeat is the infamous look
behind you scene which we've seen play
out in various forms across most Scream
movies Mindy is the new Randy so
fittingly she's the one being snuck up
on but unlike Randy she realizes it and
attempts to get out of the way this this
is partially because she knows she's in
a movie and she might be a little bit
sharper than Randy but there's also an
important clue in stab there are a
couple of VHS tapes on the table behind
stab Randy I think the top one might be
The People Under the Stairs in another
West Craven reference and I'm having a
hard time making out what the bottom one
is let me know if you recognize it but
look directly below the tv she's
watching on and you'll see three VHS
tapes two of which are the same two on
the table behind Randy there's a
slightly better look at it later when
Sam is tending to Mindy's injuries it's
definitely the same two tapes Mindy by
the way does survive which could be
related to this little line from scre
form in fact the only Sure Fire waiter
survive a modern horror movie you pretty
much have to be gay it also helps to be
the daughter of a serial killer as it
turns out she may be related to Billy
Lumis but Sam wipes her knife off a lot
more like stacher now before I get into
the ending and my views on what this
really means for the franchise I've got
to go over all of the evidence seen
throughout the film that proves Who The
Killers really were as I have at the end
of each of my scream analysis videos so
let's take it back one more time to the
start and in the opening Tara invites
Amber to come over mentioning that her
mom was out of town Amber and Richie
were probably waiting for an opportunity
like this and used it to decide that
this would be the night that they strike
when Tera starts receiving concerning
phone calls she gets a text from Amber
which says you should answer it the
caller explains that Amber's phone was
cloned and no one really questions it
but the easier and correct explanation
is that Amber was just the killer using
her own phone when Sam gets a ghost face
call in the hospital it's also from
Amber's phone Amber and Richie have to
act like they're meeting for the first
time we see her look at him very
lustfully which makes more sense now
knowing that they were secretly a couple
Sam is attacked at the hospital at the
same time that Amber was being
questioned by Hicks at the police
station which means this one must have
been Richie this is the same old trick
used to get Billy Lumis off the hook in
Scream and get Roman off the hook in
Scream 3 when are they going to learn
that there are always multiple Killers
then there's the scene where Dewey
correctly predicts a killer by accusing
Richie this is just like Randy in the
original scream his first guess is Billy
and it's correct he's got killer printed
all over his for the most damning
evidence comes after he kicks Richie and
Sam out though listen to what Richie has
to say about him
Jesus yeah he's way more fun in the
movies notice the plural use of the word
movies at this point in the story he
claims that he's only seen one stab
movie The Original when he and Sam were
driving to Woodsboro he claimed to have
no idea about the stab movies and then
at the hospital he says he's watching
the first one on Netflix so he can be
prepared lucky for him Sam doesn't seem
to notice the slip up while it's not
necessarily evidence I do think the fact
that he spends his spare time watching
vital about stab 2021 is kind of telling
about where his interests lie even if
his reasoning is that he's trying to
learn about the franchise later on
during the second attack at the hospital
Amber Cuts Richie in the forearm we saw
this in scree form where Jill was cut in
the same spot by her fellow accomplice
as a way to deflect suspicion away from
her in my previous video I labeled this
as a nod to scream to where Dereck is
cut in the forearm and Dewey finds it
suspicious because the cut conveniently
missed any major arteries despite some
of the well- Hidden evidence that I
mentioned I found these killers to be
pretty obvious perhaps the fact that
they are so so similar to The Killers
from the last movie made them stand out
a little bit more we close with the same
pull out shot of a news anchor giving a
report in front of the house but this
time it is not Gail weathers like the
main characters and the filmmakers the
news anchor microphone has been passed
down to the next generation at the end
over the dedication to the series late
former director we hear a bird
call it links back to all of the bird
artwork scen in Amber's house it's all
part of one last tribute to screams
iconic director Wes Craven who in his
spare time was an avid bird watcher the
sound at the end of scream 2022 is the
call of the Whipper will a sound effect
that Craven has actually used a few
times in his films in this 2008
interview in the bird Enthusiast
magazine Aon he explains how he has used
bird sounds as sort of an orchestration
in his work I've used the Whipper will a
few times probably inappropriately but
it's such a haunting sound and I do
remember the sound from being a kid in
the woods of Ohio and on camping trips
but yeah I think they're used a lot in
Hollywood I would be the first to
confess that accuracy is probably not
the first motive motivation we get a
quick flash of somebody in a ghost face
mask wiping off a knife before the
credits roll maybe an homage to the
quick scares seen before the credits of
scream and in Scream
2 no such scare occurs in Scream 3 or
four to me the implication is that
seeing a new ghost face right before the
end credits is teasing a sequel we don't
see it in three because Roman is
defeated and for now that means the end
of the series while Scream 4 was not
planned to be the final movie it was the
end of that era of scream and there's
nothing in the story that prevents the
fourth movie from being the Final
Chapter unlike Scream one which
specifically has a line about how
there's got to be a sequel and scream
two which specifically has a line
suggesting that it's a Trilogy so the
quick flash of ghost face at the end of
scream 2022 to me is the director's way
of telling us that they planned for a
sequel and with a sixth movie being
given the go-ahead before the fifth was
even globally released it seems likely
the next chapter was planned and it'll
tie in nicely with the material in the
offering
towards the end of Scream Six we see a
quick shot of the contacts list on Sam's
phone one of which is christe in my
scream 2022 video I pointed out the
Easter eggs hidden in the contacts on
Dewey's phone and the meaning behind
christe and the other names listed so
this is our clue to be on the lookout
for references again so let's go through
her contacts terara is her sister the
Jenna Ortega character but Meyer is the
son of Scream 6 producer William sherik
the next name is Eloise she's the
daughter of William sherik the next name
after that is Nick the fifth and sixth
scream were directed by Matt bet nelli
openin and Tyler Gillette who did a
segment in the anthology horror film VHS
where one of the characters is named
Nicki I'm not sure about River it's too
common of a word to search but I did
figure out that Eileen is Eileen Jones
the wife of Tyler Gillette Mindy and
chatter the twins from the movie Sydney
is the main protagonist of the franchise
who isn't in this one Jay is the film's
editor Jay pidy and tfer is the post-
production assistant Tyler Ferguson I
wasn't able to find a mini and Rebecca
could refer to several people but that's
just a taste of the the level of detail
that this movie secrets have to offer if
you want to know the scream origins of
every single prop in the movie theater
Shrine all of the costume references on
the subway train and info hidden in hard
to find places stick around to the end
of this video Welcome to things you
missed just one year after the franchise
was revived with Scream 2022 the next
sequel would already be released
mirroring the quick turnaround from the
original scream in 1996 to Scream 2 in
1997 this would be our first of many
clues that scream 6 was going to be a
requel of Scream 2 in the same way that
the last movie was a prequel of the
original for the third movie in a row
they changed the naming Convention of
the title the fourth movie moved the
number inside the word scream which was
cool everybody likes it when I call it
scree form it's not annoying nobody
leaves angry comments about that at all
the fifth could have gone with five
cream but instead it just decided to
call it scream to fit the meta of rals
at the time like Halloween and Candyman
I guess Scream 6 was trying to do the
best of both worlds by doing the
Standalone title but also having the
number in the M on the poster which
means they had to switch to Roman
numerals it reminds me of the Jack
franchise the first game was Jack and
Daxter the precursor Legacy then Jack 2
switches to Roman numerals Jack 3 used
Arabic numerals but then the fourth one
was called Jack X but it wasn't the
Roman numeral X it was just the letter X
anyway I'm getting off topic let's cut
in to the things you
[Music]
missed the first thing I'm going to talk
about is how similar this movie is to
Scream 2 while the characters do point
this out themselves stop two took place
in college so do we think that the
Killer is trying to copy the movies it
was much deeper than you might have
realized in addition to the college
setting one of the Five Ghost Face
killers in this movie Jason is
introduced in the opening where we find
out that he's a student in a class about
20th century slashers just like the
Killer and Scream 2 Mickey is introduced
in a college film class discussing the
stab movie both movies feature a main
character who's dealing with Newfound
Fame after surviving murders the
previous year when a new string of
crimes begins they're both given special
police protection each has a new
boyfriend who's very suspicious but not
guilty when we're reintroduced to Tara
she's on her way to a party she went to
the Omega Kappa beta party it's the same
fraternity that Derrik belonged to in
Scream to we even briefly see their coat
of arms that matches the necklace that
Derrick gave Sydney at the party we
learned that Terra is considering
joining sorority called Omega beta Zeta
you Omega beta Zeta no not yes which is
the same one that CC Cooper was a part
of in 1997 speaking of CC Cooper she
doesn't last long in the movie getting
stabbed and thrown off the top of that
sorority house she has a counterpart in
Scream Six Ana who gets stabbed and
tossed from the ladder she's trying to
escape on I don't know why Danny just
has a huge ladder in his NYC apartment
maybe he saw nerve and was inspired
terara later explains that the cor for
moved to New York for summer semester
very similar to how Sydney and Randy
moved to Ohio mid school year to escape
their own trauma in Woodsboro while
Scream 2 was set in Ohio the college
that they filmed at was in Atlanta
Atlanta is mentioned several times in
Scream 6 it's the place where Jason and
Greg first met in middle school and
Kirby works for the FBI's Atlanta field
office could be a coincidence or maybe
an intentional connection Kirby by the
way has a scar from where Charlie
stabbed her in scree form she gets
stabbed there again at the end of Scream
6 but lives the same way that Dewey
survived in Scream 2 KNE went some old
scar tissue saved his life the same
thing seems to happen to Gail Weathers
in scre form she got it in the shoulder
and that's where the new ghost face gets
her again in six and she manages to
survive after Sam and Tera survived the
first attack Gail weathers comes
investigating and the franchise
tradition of her getting punched in the
face by the victim continues if you look
at the reaction of the cameraman it's
the same look of surprise seen on the
face of Joel her camera guy in Scream to
yes I got that off the reason Gail got
punched was because Sam was unhappy with
her portrayal in Gail's latest book you
called me unstable and a Born Killer
that's taken out of context that's
literally a quote which mirrors Dewey's
frustrations with his portrayal in the
Woodsboro murders book he too supplies
her with actual citations page 41 as I
mentioned the first death out of the
main cast is Ana and she's wearing the
same green jacket that Randy wore when
he became a ghost face victim in the
second movie there's also another
reference to Randy when they're walking
through the parks trying trying to keep
ghost face on the line and this
similarity is called out by Mindy this
is exactly how our Uncle Randy died
however the person in danger here is
actually Gail who is at home during her
call with the killer she tries to locate
him by hanging up and calling back this
is also a reference to scream too turn
the phone up and star 69 is it damn the
finale of each film takes place in a
theater where all is revealed at one
point Sam grabs a brick to defend
herself with which honors the method by
which Sydney tried to defeat Billy's
mother crushing her with a pile of
bricks quck reveals herself as the final
Killer Hey roomies you didn't see that
one coming did you actually I did Billy
and Roman already tried faking their
death so it wasn't a huge surprise more
importantly her line is almost identical
to what Mickey said after the reveal of
Billy's mother SP twist huh didn't see
it coming did you like in Scream 2 the
Main ghost face is the parent of the
antagonist from the previous movie out
for revenge against their son's killer
the accomplice or in this case the
accomplices are enrolled at the
University their education being funded
by the other ghost phase in Scream two
Sydney is saved by cotton someone she
previously believed to be guilty in six
Sam and Tera are saved by Kirby who they
thought was guilty finally at the end it
turns out that Chad is somehow alive and
he's carried out in a Stretcher with
terara running alongside it's just like
Dewey and Gail at the end of Scream 2
but there would be even more scream to
references in the movie theater along
with many more hidden
[Music]
secrets part of the fun of the scream
franchise and the who done it genre in
general is going back to see the clues
laid out for us once we know the ending
in tera's dialogue with Quinn at the
apartment Quinn describes how her dad
held on too tight with
overprotectiveness after they lost her
brother combined that with Detective
Bailey's line after Quinn's death my
kids are
gone my whole
family and that's two oddly specific
references to this mysterious dead
sibling the movie honestly could have
used a few red herrings to throw us off
because it was obvious that this brother
was significant adding the fact that the
first ghost face call comes from Richie
kersh's phone and it starts to become
clear this is the same tactic that
Richie and Amber used when A call came
in from Amber's phone everyone assumed
that the killer cloned Amber's phone
number when in reality all they had to
do was use Amber's actual phone
detective Bailey probably got Richie's
phone back after his death and just used
that one area where the movie did
successfully employ a red herring was in
wardrobe fans know at this point that at
least one Ghostface Killer always has a
light blue shirt or flannel in this case
it was e and while I never really
suspected Tara or Sam we're forced to
notice Dany wearing light blue when we
literally see him put it on someone
wearing a ghost face mask attacks Sam
Tera outside their apartment the same
apartment where they were literally just
with Quinn and Ethan later on after
Quinn's death is staged her father comes
out of the building with a little bit of
a limp maybe from an injury sustained
when he's knocked to the floor by
Samantha and he's staring right at
Samantha as he says this with my
family you die and when Gail gets the
dreaded phone call later on it's from a
707 area code which represents Northern
California where Woodsboro is located
that's another clue that the Killer is
from that area which richy's family most
likely would be there's also an ominous
clue that isn't related to the identity
of the protagonist Sam psychiatrist can
be seen watching Invasion of the Body
Snatchers which literally tells
him before he becomes the next Ghostface
victim as always it's one of many horror
movie references in a scream film every
Scream movie makes a reference to Psycho
with the last film even containing a
Psycho movie poster that continues here
with this poster in Jason's apartment he
also has a vertigo poster another
Thriller directed by Alfred Hitchcock in
addition to the first psycho psycho 2 is
also referenced this time psycho 2 is
underrated psycho 2 also features a
character getting stabbed through the
mouth which is exactly what Tara does to
Ethan at the end but going back to Jason
given that he's a film student and a
horror fan there are a lot of references
connected to him the reason he killed
his professor in the opening sequence
was because she gave him a c minus on
his gialo paper gialo is an Italian
murder mystery genre a perfect
counterpart to screen Jason's t-shirt
says for mosque duto Grigio which
translates to Four Flies on the gray
velvet it's a gialo film directed by
Dario Argento about a rock musician who
becomes entangled in a gruesome murder
case interestingly Jason also has an ice
9 kills magnet on his fridge ice 9 kills
is a metal band known for theming their
songs around horror movies their 2018
album the silver scream has a series of
accompanying music videos with a
narrative through line about a series of
deaths connected to the Brand's front
man Spencer Charis so kind of similar to
Four Flies on the gray velvet ice 9
kills also did a deluxe version of the
silver scream which appropriately
contains a song about scream and no it
was not lost on me that Jason gets home
and turns on a Friday the 13th movie his
full name is Jason Carvey and Jason
Vorhees the antagonist of the Friday the
13th franchise likes to carve up his
victims this isn't just any Friday the
13th movie though it's Friday the 13th
Part 8 Jason Takes Manhattan the one
where he goes to New York much like how
Scream 6 is set in New York Jason is not
the only new character who seems to be a
horror fan Sam psychiatrist has some
merch in his office on on the desk you
can spot a lineup of horror dolls
including Gomez Pugsley and fester Adams
as well as Leatherface above the
fireplace there's also a Leatherface
doll in a ghost face doll the defunct
movie theater Marquee is advertising two
events on the left it says Jennifer
Jolie retrospective Jennifer Jolie was
the name of the actress who played Gail
Weathers in stab 3 on the right it says
Rocky Horror Picture Show which connects
to this guy dressed up as Franken ferder
from Rocky Horror on the subway which
brings me to the next section the
costumes it's always been a pet peeve of
mine in movies that take place around
Halloween when everyone is dressed in
generic costumes like vampire Pirates
nurse Etc cuz in real life most people
are dressed up as something specific
usually some kind of Pop Culture thing I
was glad to see scream finally do this
right and some of the costumes have a
deeper meaning like at the Omega Capa
beta party where we see a girl dressed
as Wednesday Adams from The Adams Family
since the release of scream 2022 the
star Jenna Ortega portrayed this
character in a popular adaptation known
as Wednesday is the recycling Wednesday
flyer on her fridge related to this as
well probably not not other party guests
include someone in a striped ghost face
mask hanging with Dwight sho from the
office there's also a girl in the crowd
wearing a number 10 Jersey a reference
to the top that Tatum wears in the first
scream which is a reference to What
Glenn Lance wore in a Nightmare on Elm
Street then we've got Harry Potter Allan
from The Hangover and Mindy Meeks who is
dressed as storet delvery a woman known
for her part in a lesbian movement in
the 1960s that's kind of her whole
entire gimmick in this movie she's
constantly advertising her homosexuality
there are even more costumes in the
subway scene first there's Grace from
the 2019 movie Ready or Not which is
directed by Matt Bonelli open and Tyler
Gillette just like this movie there's a
David Bowie in the crowd and a Michael
Myers from the Halloween franchise which
is significant because of how the scream
franchise is a satire primarily of the
Halloween franchise in fact when they
arrive at the train station you can hear
people chanting evil dies tonight scary
serial killer movie which is the Mantra
from Halloween kills the sequel to The
requel just like how Scream 6 is a
sequel to A requel the Statue of Liberty
makes an appearance makes sense it's New
York this is mojo jojo the main villain
from the Powerpuff Girls nice to see
scream staying in touch with its '90s
roots it's not really a costume but this
guy has a fangoria shirt fangoria being
the famous horror magazine on the train
there's someone dressed as the babad DU
which Tera cited as her favorite movie
in the fifth scream what's your favorite
scary movie uh the babad due other than
ghost face the train contains a variety
of other slasher icons like pin head
from the Hellraiser movies Jason from
Friday the 13th and Freddy Krueger from
A Nightmare on Elm Street of course this
wasn't fr's first rodeo in a Scream
movie there's also someone dressed as
Chucky from Child's Play which was
referenced in Scream 2022 as an example
of a horror movie that was remade that
scene also talks about elevated horror
what's wrong with elevated horror I mean
Jordan Peele rules so some of
the costumes in the subway are from the
elevated horror era like Pluto from
Jordan peels us as well as several of
the other tethered characters from that
movie there's also a chick dressed as
Danny arter aka the May Queen from
Midsummer right after that there's a
quick flash Cameo from Tyler Gillette
the the co-director before we move on to
some Stephen King references including
the grd twins from The Shining and
Georgie Den brro from it other horror
references include melany Daniels from
the birds complete with bird Horus
Pinker from West Craven shocker kayako
SEI from The Grudge and Billy the Puppet
from Saw which was mentioned in scree
form did you pick a movie yeah we're
going to go scary saw four it seems
there are also other pop culture
references on the train like Tyler Duran
from Fight Club and I didn't know what
this was so I tried Googling hand around
a neck costume and apparently was just
an Oscar's dress from Julia Fox an
actress from the movie uncut gems
there's one glaring hole in the train
scene they're trying to safely travel
from the upper west side to the movie
theater everyone is in costume around
them so why don't they just get costumes
to evade Ghost Face there are many
hidden details in the costumes and there
may even be some that I didn't recognize
so let me know what you saw in the
comments but there were even more
secrets in the form of hidden West
Craven homages scream Easter eggs and
other things you might have
missed
[Music]
if you follow my channel you know I'm
very concerned with movie timeline
accuracy I have a series called Horror
history which is half character analysis
and half timeline construction so I can
be the first to say that these last two
Scream movies have screwed up the
timeline at the end of the fifth Scream
the reporter claims that the original
Woodsboro Massacre was 25 years ago
almost to the de the original was set in
1996 so that would mean that it was set
in 2021 however Sam and Mindy both
claimed that the most recent stab came
out last year and we can clearly see
that was 2021 meaning that the fifth
scream is actually set in 2022 which
seems to be backed up in Scream 6 the
Woodsboro truther subreddit refers to
the most recent events in Woodsboro as
the 2022 Woodsboro Massacre and Kirby's
timeline of events says 2022 was the
year of Richie and Amber's death however
this board also claims that Roman's
death was in 2000 which is incorrect in
Scream 3 Roman died in 1999 the
production designers obvious obvously
just use the release dates of the movies
rather than when they are set but Kirby
specifically says that Richie and Amber
died last year so we can probably just
go with the fifth scream taking place in
2022 and the sixth scream taking place
in 2023 right well when we see the film
professor's phone at the beginning of
the movie it says Saturday October 29th
which would put this in 2022 other phone
screens also corroborate this Sam's
driver's license is 2 days away from
expiration although you could argue that
she's not planning on renewing it cuz
you don't need a car in New York and the
subway map says service suspended
through September 2022 why would that
still be up over a year later but on the
other hand the newscaster in Scream 6
very clearly refers to Sam as one of the
survivors of the Woodsboro killings in
2022 so I think there's more evidence
now that scream 2022 does in fact take
place in 2022 and scream 6 takes place
13 months later in 2023 this board also
confirms that the scream TV show is a
separate Cannon entirely which I'm very
much fine with look if anyone knows the
people that work on these movies can you
please just send them my channel so they
can stop screwing up their own franchise
I usually try to find a reason to make
the mistakes work by saying things like
uh this character was just estimating
the dates but there are only so many
excuses I can make for you Roman Bridger
was the only single Ghost Face kudos to
him for ambition that's debatable it's
extremely debatable see my Scream 3
things you missed episode for details
but not until after you've seen all the
West Craven references here in Scream
Six as you know West Craven was the
legendary horror director who brought us
everything from Last House on the Left
To The Hills Have eyes to a nightmare in
Elm Street and of course the first four
screams in Jason's apartment he has up a
poster for last podcast on the left a
clear play on Last House on the Left
that film was released in 1972 And in
the establishing shots at the beginning
of the movie we see West 72nd Street it
appears that all of the East West
streets in Upper Manhattan corresponds
to West Craven release dates the
characters board a train at 94th and
93rd which corresponds to New Nightmare
and body bags respectively Gail's
apartment is located between '96 and '97
scream came out in 1996 and Scream 2
came out in 1997 one of the posts in the
Woodsboro truther subreddit comes from a
user named 234 Mimi Mimi 23 Mimi Craven
was Wes Craven's wife for a short time
in the 80s she appeared in a Nightmare
on Elm Street and Swamp Thing Jason and
Greg's apartment building is called Elm
Court a reference to a nightmare in Elm
streams when we see Sam's driver's
license her address is 2419 Solar Drive
Modesto California however this address
is not in Modesto it's in Los Angeles
and it once belonged to West Craven this
next one is one of the weirdest ever at
the end of the convenience store scene
we see the exterior of the store and
it's called Abes snake Bodega when I'm
making these videos and I see a brand
name that I don't recognize I always
look it up to find out if there's some
significance so that's what I did and I
found this slash film article which
contains some odd trivia it explains
that one of Craven's friends got
involved in producing adult films in the
70s and he decided to try making one
himself in 1975 in between last house
and 1977's The Hills Have Eyes Craven
made the fireworks woman also known as
Angela the fireworks woman using a
spectacular pseudonym Abe snake and just
like Angela was packed with uh fireworks
Scream 6 is packed with Easter eggs
referencing the rest of the scream
franchise if you look closely at the
Woodsboro truther subreddit which by the
way the URL is
www.r woodsbro truther pretty sure
that's not how URLs work but you'll
notice that the sub was created 114 2022
this contradicts the timeline again but
at least this one is obviously just an
Easter egg it's technically the
theatrical release date of scream 2022
seen on poster even though the premiere
was cancelled another Reddit post
advertises 261 Turner Lane part two the
allnew true story this is essentially a
story about the last movies events
because 261 Turner Lane is the address
of the house once occupied by stumacher
and his family before being the host of
Amber Freeman and her family I'm at
steer's house on Turner Lane it's 261
Turner Lane despite leaving Woodsboro
some of the characters still seem to
have pride about their Old Town Chad
hangs on to his letterman jacket and
Mindy wears a panther patch on hers the
mascot of Woodsboro High one of the
defining in characteristics of a recel
is rehashing existing scenes and scream
six is no exception Sam and Tera visit
the police station following their
convenience store encounter where
they're told that they can't leave town
by the detectiv in the fourth scream
Dewey and Judy have to tell Sydney the
same thing another Sydney parallel can
be seen as they're leaving and the media
swarm around them just like when they
mobbed Sydney Prescott in 1996 outside
of the Woodsboro police station and the
same music plays as well eventually
Kirby shows up now a member of the FBI
and she and Mindy test each other on
horror movie knowledge best Nightmare on
Elm Street the original this is a
reference to the original screen where
Casey Becker has similar taste yeah
Freddy Krueger Freddy that's right I
like that movie it was scary well well
the first one was but the rest sucked or
maybe just common sense then there's
Gail during the part where she's talking
with Sam about the importance of family
we hear Dewey's theme in the background
suggesting that Gail never stopped
caring about him this is also evident
because she has the same photo of her
and Dewey that we first saw in dey's
trailer in the fifth one she almost
ended up joining him after an ambush by
Quinn at one point she fires two shots
through the door and says how's that for
Nostalgia referring to when she
played Hero by shooting Billy Lumis way
back in the original but it wasn't just
the dialogue that was nostalgic because
the movie theater Shrine is packed with
background details spanning the entire
franchise before heading into the
theater for the final show down Sam
splits off from her new love interest
Danny for safety reasons we don't know
you not really she says this in almost
the exact same way as her old love
interest Richie spoke about the stab
franchise no one has made a great stab
movie since the first one not really
from this point on there's a lot of
familiar line delivery I've always
wanted to stick something in you teror I
always had it thing for you s the movie
theater Shrine is a gold mine for things
you missed akin to Elanor Studio from
jigsaw I'll start with the first scream
and work my way forward this is the
outfit Tatum Riley wore on her final
night this is Stu Maker's robe from the
night of his party and here's Billy
Lumis his shirt from that same evening
the black jacket and backwards hat
belong to Kenny Gail's cameraman for top
story with Gail weathers it's more
obvious when you see the back of his top
story jacket this mannequin represents
Steven orth Casey's boyfriend and the
franchise's first onscreen kill here we
have the ghost face mask that principal
hry confiscated from the pranksters at
the school and cut up and these are the
scissors he used to do it two of your
fellow students just savagely murdered
and this is the way that you show your
compassion and sensitivity huh let me
show you something you're both expelled
yeah you know I wonder if they just
showed up at school the next day it's
not like hry had time to tell anyone
that he expelled them on top of the Mask
is the rope that hry swung from next to
a sketch of where he was found on the
football field and his obituaries this
is an employee shirt from Bradley Video
Store the store that Randy worked at in
the first movie I'm not positive why
this is here because as far as we know
nobody died at the video store storm but
I guess it's possible that it was still
a scene in the movie adaptation of stab
rounding out the first movie we have the
Woodsboro High School flag Scream 2
opens with the stab movie premiere and
there's a lot of memorabilia from that
we see the costumes masks and plastic
knives that were handed out to patrons
and attendance at the premiere as well
as a few movie tickets in the corner is
the giant ghost face head that decorated
the production office in Scream 3 this
sketch depicts Sydney at various points
in Scream 2 on stage in the government
car and at the library it's above a
Windsor College sweater the setting of
Scream 2 I believe the camera that Chad
picks up and throws at ghost face is
Joel's camera during his gig with up to-
dat this big old set piece along the
side of the theater is the thing that
Derek was tied to at the end of Scream 2
and at some point we can even see the
Agamemnon mask that he was wearing when
he was lowered onto the stage there's
also another mask from that play right
here there's also a glimpse of the white
Blazer that Debbie salt SL Nancy Lumis
was wearing during the finale and I
believe this is the gun that she used
during that scene Scream 3 is all about
the production of the third stab movie
being terrorized by a new threat the
stab 3 script is the Slate used during
filming however as an Easter egg the
cinematographer is listed as Brett jukt
the cinematographer of scream 2022 and
scream six I spotted a sketch of Sarah
Darling the first Scream 3 victim and
Jennifer Jolie the actress who played
gal also visible here is the Killer's
voice changer in gun Scream 3 had a
special voice changer that allowed the
user to imitate anyone's voice kind of
funny that we've only just recently
unlocked that technology today and it's
being used to make politicians bicker
over video games in this case there's a
melted phone a frying pan and a lighter
the frying pan is the one that the
killer used to knock out the security
guard Steven Stone there's another
frying pan attack in this movie when
Gail uses it against Quinn I wonder if
that one will make the next Museum the
phone is Jennifer Jolie's phone damaged
when her house exploded and the lighter
must have been Tom Prince's lighter
which was responsible for causing that
explosion overhead is the banner that
says happy birthday Roman which was
displayed over the entryway of John
Milton's Manor when Sydney arrived it
was not a happy birthday for Roman scree
form by the time this one rolled around
several more stab films had been made
these posters for stabs 3 four and five
are all in scree form but this is the
first time we've ever seen the stab four
poster or should I say the storb poster
unobstructed there are also sketches of
the two killers Charlie and Jill as well
as the shirt that Charlie was wearing
when he died and the flannel that Jill
had on before being taken to the
hospital and changed into a hospital
gown there's a moment where we see Kirby
looking at it with tears in her eyes
remembering the way that her best friend
betrayed her and tried to have her
killed and we also see the knife that
Charlie stabbed her with and the res do
on the patio where Kirby was tied up in
the back here you'll see the outfit worn
by Jill's ex-boyfriend Trevor when he
died it could also potentially be Neil
Prescott's outfit from Scream one which
looks the same but since Neil never died
I'm guessing he got to keep his clothes
I see no reason they would have ended up
in police custody this one was the
hardest to place my first thought was
that it was supposed to be Casey Becker
because nobody else died in a white long
sleeve but it doesn't match and she
wasn't wearing shorts my guess is that
it's actually supposed to be Jill's
neighbor Olivia Morris who was taking
down while wearing a gray long sleeve
and flannel shorts it's not a perfect
match but it's my best guess there's
also a Woodsboro police uniform meaning
that this belonged to Deputy hos or
Deputy Perkins the two cops who fell in
the line of duty while parked outside of
Jill's house and we have a stabon
t-shirt stabon was the movie marathon
event hosted by the Woodsboro High film
club where Gail weathers was nearly
butchered in addition to those there's
also a case full of Gail's books most of
which we've seen before in Scream 3 and
four with one notable
addition
[Music]
the Gail weathers book that we haven't
seen before is stabbed in the back the
real Sunrise story this actually comes
from one of the promotional websites for
Scream 3 Sunrise sucks this was an
anonymous expose site that published
dirt about the production company
responsible for the stab franchise
Sunrise Studios I talk about it
extensively in my Horror history episode
on the history of the stab IP by the way
in Gail's apartment there's one new
boook book called The Woodsboro horror
continues which must be the one she
wrote about the 2022 or whenever it took
place Woodsboro Massacre all of these
theater Shrine items were part of Richie
kersh's Collection despite the fact that
he claims that the first stab movie is
the only good one he dies in Scream 2022
so it makes sense that there wouldn't be
much from that movie however I did
notice the stab Blu-ray box set which
was released at some point between
screams 4 and five if there's one thing
you can usually count on in a requel
it's the new characters taking up the
mantle of the Legacy characters in the
case of scream Sam Carpenter is the new
Sydney Prescott and she puts on the
ghost face costume to fight back against
detective Bailey at the end of the movie
It's the very same Ghost Face costume
that Sydney wore to strike back against
Billy Lumis approximately 27 years
earlier and just like Billy Bailey finds
himself on the wrong end of a ghost face
call from his
prey hello detective Bailey you sure did
it hello are you alone in the house
Bailey is not the only one to suffer a
very 1996 fase Ethan pops up in the
final reel for one last scare and gets
crushed by the same TV that fell upon
Stu mocker so what's the message this
time what are the filmmakers trying to
tell us well it's not that different
from the last movie this is kind of the
second one in a row that condemns toxic
internet culture this time instead of
toxic fandom it's about the phenomenon
of Reddit detectives who try to solve
crimes on their own and usually just end
up making things worse wavy web surf has
a really good video on the topic if you
want to learn more throughout the movie
Sam has to deal with accusations that
she was actually the killer in Woodsboro
like this guy who refers to her as being
that psycho girl he looks like he could
be an actual redditor another chick
recognizes her dumps Diet Cherry Coke on
her and calls her a murderer why would
you dump a beverage on someone if you
believe she was a murderer that is not a
smart move even her psychiatrist starts
to get creeped out by her if you're like
me you probably wanted to go back and
look at the names of the psychiatrist
filing cabinet to see if there were any
Easter eggs as far as I can tell these
are just random patient names with no
deeper meaning but Mars Jupiter is
definitely a weird one perhaps the
biggest twist with this movie is that
none of the core characters died it
looked like Chad was a goner there for a
minute minute but he miraculously makes
it out on a stretcher at the end
although during that part where Tera
takes off his oxygen mask to kiss him I
wish he just would have died right there
it would have been so funny
click the playlist on the left for more
of my scream franchise analysis videos
and if you want to see everything you
might have missed in the upcoming Scream
7 then make sure you subscribe to cz's
world for new Horrors every week ring
the death bell for all notifications and
I will see you in the next one assuming
we both
[Music]
survive